How many people are live right now?
>> Okay. 27,000 people is a lot of people. That means your
voice really matters. >> I believe that this weird like
sudden Zionism that overcame her is and like fervent Zionism
is entirely because of that Israel trip connected somehow and
she is now getting money in relation to >> that is not
what due process means. >> Okay. Due process that's part
of all of due process. Due process the process of pushing against
allegations against you. >> No, no, no, no, no. And who's
they? Who's they? Don't say the don't say the Larry Olsen and
uh Miriam Aden,
Alex Dy, Kyla, Trump preps boots on the ground in Ron. Media
says media. Trump says no. Tim Cast IRL with deery darkens.
So Aerodite's number one criticism of Trump. Let's go. >> It
seems like the war plan is not the most effective.
Do you guys want to see a plan of like if you say that you're
ending the war? How
>> Kylo be like nonsense, nonsense, nonsense, right? Nonsense,
nonsense, nonsense. Right. Right. >> How are you winning?
>> This is how he wins the war, though. He negotiates with
Putin, who's Iran's biggest ally, and then he simultaneously
ends the war in Ukraine while ending this war. And then it can
look like he did a two for one deal. >> What if Putin won't
end the war? >> You know, he just said he just said today
that he Putin's been more receptive than Zalinsky in all of his
negotiations. Sure, but he's he's like gone back and forth on
Putin, right? Like Putin's been more receptive, but Putin's still
sending Iran important intelligence, right? So it's like and
Putin's been pretty clear. He's not ending with Ukraine. Like
if he he wants Crimea, he wants the Dawnbast. That's not changing,
which >> he maybe get it. Maybe Trump will give it to him.
Give Crimea in the Donbass. >> He's already got Crimea
in the Dawnbast. >> Well, he's got Crimea, but the the
fighting is still around in the Dawnbast area. And regardless
how you feel about it, I can't imagine the Ukrainians are going to
take that laying down. They're not going to >> choice.
I don't think they're going to have a choice. I I don't think
that at the very least I don't think Crimea is going back. He
wants the port. >> I I I agree that Crimea is a is a fighting
thing. But uh regardless, um it's not obvious to me because of
all these moving. >> He did take the sanctions off their
oil >> for Russia's oil. Yeah. >> So that's a pretty
big step for effort. >> He wants to bring him to the petro
dollar. He wants to cut them back in and say we're going to make
you money and you should be working with us because you're western.
Well, I think the petro dollar is what's in limbo right now because
if all of these Gulf, you know, >> God, it's going to be
painful to listen >> States don't actually feel like we're
providing them any safety, then they don't even have to use the
petro dollar and then we'd be totally screwed because we have
nothing that backs our currency. So, it's like I feel like this
is a very slippery slope if this thing goes even more sideways.
>> You just start sinking oil tankers because you're the
only country with submarines. You're the only country that can
cross the ocean. You're literally the only country. You're it.
That's it. There's only one. You just sink oil tankers. They
all die. They all lose immediately. Why do you think do you People
say this people say well actually the petro dollar backs our
currency and like there's nothing else. So people just gave America
free [__] for no reason for decades. Is that actually
what happened here? People just gave America free. They're just
like you know what we love when you like with our elections.
We love when you support our enemies. We love when you cause
chaos around the world. We love when you run the world like it's
your own playground. We love that so much. Here's money and we're
never going to ask for anything in return. That's what everybody
says.
What delusional world do these people live in where apparently
a manifest destiny means everybody gives us free all the time
forever. No, there's a reason that this whole system works. There's
a reason people will buy your bonds. There's a reason that the
US dollar is the reserve currency for everybody on the planet
and this whole petro dollar system is upheld.
It's the Navy stupid
>> ways. Yeah. Yeah, I mean look that this is like I said
earlier, this is still a a military success for the United States
like the US. I think that when Iran is saying that that they've
they >> reserve currency doesn't mean people give you free
though. That's not what I >> They've achieved something
because they managed to hit one F-35.
Like that's a big deal to them considering all the sorties that
have gone over. You got B-52s which are not stealth aircraft.
They're flying over there basically at at their, you know, at
their whim. They they've got total air domination if I understand
correctly. Um the you can't say that Iran is >> that's
what I just said, Klein Hila. That's literally what I just said.
That's why the dollar is stable. That's why the dollar is what
everybody holds. That's why everybody thinks the longest lasting
thing in the world. Even still, it's the US dollar. That's that's
what it's all about. Okay. Yeah. It's >> winning the war.
The fact of the matter is the US doesn't have the there isn't
a likelihood that the US is going to achieve its political goals.
And that's that's
consistently what the US has been doing. They'll achieve the
military goals, but actually getting the political goals is is
something that has eluded the US for >> that's Iran's win
condition, right? If the win condition for the regime is the
regime stays in power, then if America backs off before the regime
has crumpled and and regime change has happened, the regime is
going to say we won. is going to likely further solidify their
very antagonistic position towards Israel and America and we're
going to be left with this state that's extremely hostile towards
America with potentially concerns again about are they going
to begin just rebuilding their nuclear
>> just argue to nuke them just argue to nuke them or argue
that America needs to send troops in for Israel
these are the two arguments
but don't don't just say well I don't know what to do cuz like
they're Islamic they're the Islamic Republic. They say death
to America. I don't know what to do. You do know what you want.
Nuke them or put American boots on the ground. That's your two
options. Don't do this this like negative argument around this
old doesn't Israel have the right to exist? Doesn't that mean
that like if people are firing rockets us at us in Lebanon, we
get to destroy all the civilian infrastructure in Lebanon? No,
it doesn't mean that actually. Nope. doesn't mean that.
No, no, Sasquatch. I'm talking about a mainland. You need a mainland
invasion of Iran. Argue for a mainland invasion of Iran or nuking
Iran beyond recovery or shut up. Don't do this. Well, if we don't
do anything, then the regime's can still go be there. It hates
America. Then all all you needed to do was just never go in,
right? Just let them do what they want. >> Do we do we
need to crush them right
uh it's just so tough to uh evaluate. I think the issue is without
having a proper I think you guys said Starlink got opened for
thinking about it, right? Like I I think without regime change,
I don't see how this ends because the current regime won't negotiate
with us. They are going to continue to pursue nuclear warheads
since they seem explicitly interested in >> Why? Who said
that? Why do you believe that? Why do you believe that? Why do
you believe that? Why do you believe that? Why do you believe
that? Why do you believe that
NYSE is pro-regime change? I want to come out and say that she
is not taking money from any national interest or any Zionist
interest. That you're not taking private money under the table
cuz I do believe 100%.
I'm sorry. And this is pure schizophrenia. I do not have any
proof of this at all. I believe that this weird like sudden Zionism
that overcame her is and like fervent Zionism is entirely because
of that Israel trip connected somehow and she is now getting
money in relation to that. And that's by the way there's no supporting
evidence for that at all. She technically doesn't have to respond
to me cuz I am asserting it with no evidence. Okay, aside from
her conversations and stuff I this doesn't make sense. Okay.
>> Was she not always a Zionist? She orbits destiny. Not
this level of Zionism. But like when I'm saying Zionist here,
I'm saying you're basically advocating for the thing nobody wants,
right? This is the Israel first position. Now I'm
more now. But again, so the argument is >> the the favorable
position is that we win this decisively. We remove the Iranian
regime. >> Well, but the issue is can you do that from
top down bomb? >> No, you have to do it with ground force.
>> So do we send should we send in the >> Well, it's
inevitable. They're already going to they're already going to
be >> Hold on. I don't think we need to send in troops
to accomplish that. >> You cannot occupy street corners
with fighter jets. >> You can with nuclear bombs. >> You
can't.
>> At least Alex Stein's got some balls. >> 1.5 trillion.
We have to have the technology that >> there is no technology
to enforce local laws at the root level. You need boots on the
ground. It is there's nothing about it >> that that So,
>> oh god, is Tim P going to be the smartest person on
this pl on this
Have you guys cursed me to watch something where Tim Pool is
going to be the most intelligent person on the
say no. >> Imagine policing, right? We want to go in and
we want to tell these people you cannot have this form of government.
>> Well, if we're not there to enforce what they're doing,
they're going to do whatever they want.
>> But I wouldn't do that. I would be arming the opposite
party.
Yeah, the >> there's an argument in Iran for arming the
because Iran is very different than Afghanistan in Iraq, right?
The issue is that like in the case of the opposition, they're
so beaten down by the regime, there's no coordination, they have
no access to weaponry. So this is where the boots and ground
comes of like if we hadn't started striking Iran, is there this
question of before any of this happened, could we have gotten
weapons in to some actual legitimate?
Only if you'd planned only if you'd planned and really expected
to rely on regime change happening or rely on a rebellion happening.
You would have had to plan
The fact that there are no weapons in there, but Israel could
build a drone factory in there obviously means that this wasn't
planned, that they didn't really expect this to happen. They
built a drone factory in Iran inside their
and they can't get weapons in. uh more friendly to dem democracy
group that could have had a successful regime change. That's
a big notch. Who knows? >> You bring up Afghanistan, but
there is a huge difference when you compare Iran's military which
had 900,000 people in their three different branches and you
look at the Taliban, they had 40,000 people. So, it's just going
to be and then what it took 20 years to replace a Taliban with
a Taliban. >> But the populace is very different, right?
Iran has a very high >> the populace is different
in that they're trained militarily. No.
Are they going to do philosophy? Are they going to they're going
to bring everybody who are IRGC members who are besieged members
over with like philosophy and mathematics?
Very highly educated population, very anti-regime population,
and they're going to they're just going to with poetry win over
the regime. No, there's a bunch of there's there's hundreds of
thousands of soldiers or loyal militants around that regime who
will be armed. How are you going to get that many guns in the
country? Highly educated, high large middle class populace.
highly educated. They're really smart guys. What? Okay. And >> the
populace is very different, right? Iran has a very highly educated
high large middle class populace that has a large interest in
regime change that does not like the regime that is asking for
support in shifting regime. >> Why don't we ask this question?
Is Iraq better off today than it was when we went in? >> I
don't even know. Well, the Kurds say yes, but >> No, but
but think about their current government today. Is >> America
gets nuked repeatedly by China. Is America better off today than
it was before? Well, the like
the Amish say yes. The Amish are like, "Wow, we've returned to
like a totally tranquil, non-technological way of living." The
Amish say yes.
I'm not asking about a tiny subset of the population. Kurds are
not that tiny a subset, but still still. Is it better than when
it when we went in? >> I mean, maybe marginally, but I
I don't know enough about what's going on inside Iraq now to
say to say definitively. >> I mean, what was the worst
thing Saddam Hussein did? He did mustard gas. He mustard gas.
>> No, no, no. He tried trading oil with the euro. >> I
know. And that's why he market off. He tried to do the same thing.
He Yeah, he wanted African. >> He was brutal to his people
as well, but obviously as >> well, but we don't care about
that. I mean, I >> agree. I agree. I'm just a bunch of
countries that are brutal to the people. The US is a lie. We
don't care about that. Oh god, how bad do your arguments have
to be? Every person who argued that the regime was going to change
is just like Eerodite. You guys have such an indefensible position
that total like Tim Pool and Alex Stein could pick you apart.
Doesn't that
What other topic can they do that on? There is no other topic.
There is no other way this works.
>> But but if you're if you're an oil producing nation
and you're like we want to trade with something else, we're like
then you're going to die. >> Well, the key question here
is is regime change possible? Right? We've done it successfully
in South Korea. We've done it successfully in Japan. We've done
it successfully in a number
>> South Korea.
Was there I actually don't even know. Was there South Korean
regime change? What was the what was the thing in South Korea
for regime change? I actually don't know the history there. Would
that have been that would have been pre Korean war or something,
right? That would be some pre Korean war notion.
US canceled the elections. Oh, interesting. Install the dictator.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. We kind of installed our guys there. is that
that's literally like one of the impetuses for the Korean War.
So, hold on. The Korean War. All right. And then
we saw the president in South Korea. Okay. And then what was
the other one she said? >> Right. We've done it successfully
in South Korea. We've done it successfully in Japan. We've done
it >> How'd they get it done in Japan? >> Successfully
in a number of block countries that left us
actual uh they had a resistance movement. They they were they
were actually fighting invasion. Well, that's why Iran is interesting
because it's a lot in many ways it's it's very different than
South Korea obviously point out that it's not technically regime
change. It was supporting the existing regime.
>> Yeah. But in the case of Japan, it was like actual regime
change, right? And and now they're closest allies. And there's
really >> is it it's kind of crazy how
>> two nukes, bro? The nukes might be the kinder thing
than the firebombing campaign. The firebombing campaign killed
like a hundred times more people, didn't it?
The nukes were like a show of force. But the thing about the
nukes was that
the US basically Japan thought, oh, the US can just do this as
much as they want, right? Which wasn't the case at all. The the
when they thought the nukes they thought the firebombing was
bad and then they thought the nukes were going to rain down like
the firebombing was raining down and they were like, "Oh, me
in the ass." And they're like, "Okay, we surrender. It's over.
Okay. Okay. Okay. But they didn't actually kill as many people.
I don't think I don't think I thought the I thought the firebombing
was just way crazier. Was way worse is motivated by I know there
were multiple factors for why they dropped the nukes.
I'm just saying that like the nukes actually
like to break Japan's spirit. It wasn't just
>> to break Japan's spirit. It was a combination of starving
them to death for a long period of time as that war was starting
to be lost. It was a It was starving them to death, starving
them of energy, firebombing the [__] out of them,
and then nuking them eventually. It was like total devastation.
Complete and utter devastation across the board. Oh, the Soviets
were in Manuria. Oh. Oh, I didn't even know that. Oh, that's
an interesting part of history. So, basically was like, well,
we could surrender to the Soviets or we could surrender to the
Americans. Let's surrender to the Americans. Dude, that's crazy
that Japan must have been hearing things about the USSR like
coming over and they're like, "You know what? The guys the guys
we did Pearl Harbor to, we've been like fighting like wombats,
like crazy honey badgers across the Pacific. I'd rather throw
ourselves at their mercy." >> That came out of the Pentagon
as to like why we failed in Iraq and Afghanistan. And like these
things I'm listing like middle class, high levels of education,
psychological interests of the people like growing towards specifically
the regime change that America's trying tends to lead to more
successful regime change. Whereas in Afghanistan, there's a number
of >> Hold on. She's describing she's not describing successful
reg Oh, she's doing something here that is smuggling. Okay, it's
smuggling in. She's arguing that the regime change takes better
if you are changing a bad regime to a good regime or if you're
just doing regime change in general. That if you're trying to
improve the quality of lives of the people, if it's in a place
with a middle class and higher quality of educa, higher education
that has a better chance of working. Um maybe I don't even know
if that has to do with education. It probably has to do with
like level of lifestyle, right? that people who are used to a
high level of lifestyle will not fight as brutally will not like
will not fight to the the like down to the I don't know like
to the last man. They won't fight to the last man. They'll go
okay we surrender and then they'll go back to trying to build
their lives. I do wonder how Iran would handle it at this point.
But you need to actually have regime change first. Right. The
issue you're not really describing a middle class doesn't help
you go and fight a war. That's like not what a middle class does
at all. Right? The middle class is not helping you fight the
resistance. The middle class is like, "Okay, now that the regime
is in, there's like some stabilizing factor. They've got business.
They've got people who are wealthy and can build the economy.
That probably helps you stabilize,
but that is not displacing the existing regime. That doesn't
help with that." >> Areas where we like didn't work nearly
closely enough with locals. We supported oftent times like other
counterterrorist groups rather than looking for like an alternative
in the middle. There was like a lot of major mission mistakes
that didn't happen in other successful regime change, which poses
a question, is it possible? >> I want to say this about
regime change, though. If Donald Trump thinks that he can influence
regime change in Iran, but he can't even influence the regime
of New York City, I think he's going to have an old battle. So,
>> yeah, distance is a really, really big >> Yeah,
I want to go back to what you >> Yeah, he was just meaning
on you. He wasn't actually making a serious point. >> Should
we absolutely destroy the IRGC?
I think you have to do that. >> You have to >> because
there's no reason you go in here, you spend the money, you spend
the time and the resources to go there and that's not the ending
objection. >> I kind of think, you know, looking at everything
that's going on, looking at the sentiment, looking at the media
landscape, I wonder if the American America as a hedgeimonyi
is is done. It's gone. >> The uh uh there's hegeimmani,
dude. Dude, if the global economy like breaks down right now,
America and thank god Canada. Canada,
we're we're like some of the only people who are sitting pretty.
If we lose this whole global, you know, just in time manufacturing
economy and people stop trading this way,
so many places are globed
more from the failing of US hedgemony
than everybody but the US.
I'm not joking. There's like literally nobody who's going to
do well in that except the United States. I If you don't understand
that, I don't know what to tell you.
>> There's a lot of money to be made for what what we've
seen over the over the past decade or so with global content.
Meaning making content that plays to a multicultural audience.
The simplest form of this is these uh just for laugh gags videos
that have been viral for a decade plus where it's comedy bits,
but there's no English in it. That way it can be played for anybody.
So if you're in the age of the internet and you're a business
and you want to make money, especially with media content, targeting
as many people around the world as possible, is going to make
you the most money. You're going to be like, imagine if some
dude like lived in Malaysia and just all day post about
Miles. >> We get the joke, Alex.
>> I thought it was a real question. I don't know. Imagine
somebody lived in Malaysia but posted nothing about American
politics so they could run content in the United States, sell
ads against it. The same thing is true for everywhere else. So
if you can find a lowest common denominator
cultural icon or item to produce content around, then I mean
so we're seeing that with AI slop content. We see that with comedy
content, but American centric content is going to struggle against
a sea of of easy produced slop and global lowest common denominator
content. If you want to maximize your audience, think about subjects
that get the best amount of play globally and play that. And
do you think the American as a hegemonic power plays well globally?
>> Uh Tim is explaining something here that I don't know
if he wants to explain. Okay. Tim just explained a phenomenon
I see on Twitter. Okay.
That I don't participate in necessarily, but I do see it a lot.
Okay. Tim just explained the popularity of tweets like this.
Find something that the whole world can agree upon. I posted
this the other day. I didn't even like it before posting it.
Okay. I didn't want to do that. I don't want to do that. But
that's that turns out that's the language of the world. Okay.
Even more than English.
It's
Turns out everybody hates these. Hey, they keep killing a bunch
of civilians. Not good. Not good. >> I don't think it does.
>> Have you heard of Straw Berita? the the AI slop cartoons
that are like super popular. Have you guys heard of it? >> Is
it like similar to like the Italian brain rot that came out?
>> Exactly. It's like the Italian brain rot videos, but
except they give them these terrible AI scripts. And Tim, they're
getting hundreds of millions of views on TikTok. Like it is the
the biggest AI slop I've ever seen. So, you're exactly right
when it comes to how they can just make crappy content and people
watch it. >> But that's where we're going. I mean, when
you look at uh uh like again, what's what's happening on YouTube
and this is a big deal. We've been talking about it for quite
a bit. >> Yeah, we can do >> no like YouTube's dead.
I I I would argue because fun is a platform and a monetary machine
is probably doing really really well. But the amount of AI content,
we don't we don't even have to call it slop. It's just the amount
of content being produced. It is becoming
The the the line used to be that an individual needed even a
just a tiny bit of talent to make a video that might get some
views. Even to just make the video, to turn the camera on, press
Come.
It's so [__] up that Tim is arguing this. Tim, you
I I I don't want to say the obvious thing, but Tim, you disproved
it years ago.
That's not That's never been true. Tim,
you are the proof against
Hold on.
>> Yeah, we just played this. Thank you for You stopped
watching the stream while you looked for it. Yeah. Thank you.
Now, you've got this one video where a dude was explaining how
he does something like a h 100red grand per month or 80 grand
per month, working two hours a day by just clicking a button
on an AI website and generating a video and then uploading it.
>> And he and he's like, "Yeah, I do like 10 of these per
day." And he's like, "And I make 80 grand a month." It's like,
"Okay, it's a that that kid is a millionaire and you can't compete
with that. We can't compete with that. Nobody can." And as much
as people are going to say like, "I don't want it. It doesn't
matter because it's what becomes available." There's going to
be 700 videos that's AI AI trash and there's going to be two
or three legit. >> So what's going to happen here is people
are going to realize that everybody who falls into this like
slop algorithm like this
doesn't give any return to advertisers, advertisers will look
for ways to explicitly circumvent being placed on this kind of
content because it will provide no return. Nobody is buying anything
from these forms of ads at all. Maybe they're getting overmonetized
right now. Maybe places are pay, maybe different sites are paying
way too much for them. But trust me, the people who just slowly
scroll through AI videos only, they are not going to go and buy
some product. They're not looking to do that. They are there
to like turn their brains off
So, if your content is good and you are producing something people
want to watch, especially people with a pulse, people with some
level of like intellect, people who have earning potential, you
will still make money. you will be fine.
>> Legitimate conversations about war in Iran. And what's
going to happen is that shows like this will not be able to survive
this era. I do think there's a big shift happening. I believe
that >> totally wrong. Completely wrong. Entirely wrong.
>> The narrative machine is coming back. It's going to
be impossible for independent personalities to actually express
opinions on these matters. And
we talked about it before, but my >> you are a that people
don't like. You had a way you had a massively overinflated ego
from a time when nobody else was doing your kind of stuff and
when your I guess your brother or something Tim's brother apparently
figured out some some algorithm tricks early on that got them
really big. Okay.
The fact that your is slowly dying off is not indicative of anybody
else having this problem is you had the era of free music then
you get the streaming music services where you subscribe. You
had the era of free movies and now it's just Amazon where people
just click the button and buy the movie or watch it on Paramount
or CBS or whatever. The same thing is going to happen to all
podcasts. It's already happening. So, expect my friends in the
next couple of years. You know what? I'm going to let you guys
in on a secret. I'm going to tell you exactly what the play is
right now behind the scenes. You guys ready for this one? Uh
people are going to get mad at me for saying this and maybe this
is going to be bad for my career, but I'm going to tell you what
the uh the perceived plan is based on the powers that be and
the rumors that are circulating in DC is >> what is he
going to say? What do we think he's going to say? I'm trying
to predict I'm trying to think of how I would predict what he's
going to say here. I don't know what to say. I don't know. I
think you'll always have the ability to sell something to people
like the people who sub to you directly. Those people found your
content. I guess maybe
do you try to do like memes to help people in this way? I don't
know. I'm actually unsure, man. What? I'm trying to think of
how this would go. Clipping. No, it's not. It's not about giving
in. I'm trying to think of I Listen, let's just listen to what
he >> Joe Kent is friends with Donald Trump. Joe Kent did
not resign in opposition. He did not resign because he hates
Israel or he's concerned about Israel. He did not resign because
he's concerned about this war. He resigned intentionally to create
a bifurcation in the right to shift the political parties in
the next couple of years and he's going to run for office likely
with Tulsi Gabbard in 2028. These conversations have been happening
behind the scene for some time. Tulsi Gabbard is unelectable.
Joe Kent hasn't shown himself to be particularly electable.
What the are you talking about, man? What the What the are you
talking about? I I'm like, oh, he's my He went way in the opposite
direction of where I thought he was going. I thought when he
said that that he was going to go and say something that was
obvious to everybody. And so what I was trying to think about
was like what is the obvious thing that he's going to say about
how you should shift content strategy right now? What's the like
very clear thing that you should be doing and thinking about
in terms of shifting content strategy? And I was like oh there
would be something and I should be able to think of it. But he
actually went in a totally direction I could never have predicted.
actually Kent Gabbard 2028
brother neither party would elect them
among many people in these circles if you follow Laura Loomer
she's talked about something going on with Tulsi Gabbard and
uh potentially she's working with Trump very well what I can
tell you is I have heard a handful of things in the DC area and
that is Joe Kent didn't just all of a sudden do a 180 on Trump
this is part of the game plan they want to eliminate woke they
want to restructure the political parties around a moderate Democrat
party and a neocon Republican party that reflects more like the
Obama McCain years. That way you have a Democrat candidate who
says we might have to go to war, but we we should we should bring
some of our troops home. So you're going to have maybe war and
yes war and there's not going to be a strong anti-war element
despite what people are claiming right now. The play and that
and that's one of the reasons we're seeing this play. >> Well,
Tucker Tucker runs he's anti-war. You should talk into your microphone.
>> I'm saying if Tucker runs, he's >> No, he's not.
What what we're hearing in
>> Why would anybody listen to run anything? This isn't
even the tweet. There's another tweet like this, right? There's
another tweet where he said, "According to people I've I've talked
to." Yes. Source source tells me Charlie is stable. Please God,
this is the one. This is the one I wanted,
brother. This is what everybody is saying behind the scenes.
Okay. Tell me what your sources are saying, Tim. Your sources
seem pretty infalluable. Why don't you tell me what your sources
are saying, buddy? >> I saw yesterday you said that the
right was shifting. You said the left would be pro-war and the
right would be anti-war. Has Have you heard something different?
>> No, no, no. That Tulsi Gabbard is going to be the anti-intervention
Democrat.
>> Oh, okay. >> Yeah, I didn't. Yeah, when Tim explained
this to me, I was surprised at >> Dude, Zeny Alex Stein
looking good. Okay. Alex Stein, all Alex Stein needed was a Ze
prescription, and he's rocking it now. Let's go. >> Let's
go. Tulsi, Tulsi and Kent will flip to >> guys got some
facial definition
>> It's out of control. >> Dems or Tulsi will flip
to
>> So again, I don't All I can tell you is I've heard a
handful of things. >> Literally everybody on this panel
thinks Tim's totally. That that wasn't even made clear, by the
way, that they're not going to run Republican, they're going
to run Democrat.
Telsey Gabbert and Joe Kent running Democrat in 2028 in
where what would they even be allowed in the primary?
>> from people in DC who work in the space that have like
So there's a lot of >> Honest to God, if Tulsi Gabbard
is free to run in a primary for 20 Oh, no. Hold on. No, no, no.
She never mind. She can run in 2028. if she's free to run in
2032, something's gone drastically
>> And uh it sounds to me based off a few things. Let me
stress this. What I can tell you, I know for sure. The mandate
of the corporate media right now is to buy podcasts, to absorb
them into their infrastructure and put them on the front page
of their streaming services. Duh. Look at what's happening with
CBS. Look what's happening with Tik Tok. The play is the the
machine state wants the narrative control back. So they're flooding
YouTube with AI content to suppress independent commentary and
channels. They will all get very small. They'll still exist,
but they won't have a big impact on the general perception of
what's going on in the media. Then you're going to need to reshift
the political parties. So you can have I would describe it as
a Kyla Democrat party. Still kind of on the left, but more reasonable
when they have a conversation, trying to make sound arguments.
I respect that. But you're the the weirder elements of woke and
all of the weird gender stuff is going to slowly be be pushed
aside and you're going to get a Tulsi Gab that is like uh moderate
Dem with some social policies, but the strategy is when she comes
out she solid push back right there. I believe in that stuff.
>> Will not say Trump is bad. >> We can see that
it's very strong. The belief is strongly held. It's very um very
powerful. I kind of believe in that >> She will say I believe
Trump did his >> What? Wait, did you just talk? I gotta
believe in that stuff. >> The best with the information
that he was given. I respect him. I'm not going to speak ill
of this man. >> Hey, Kyle, why do you think all of them
basically think you're a Republican? Why do you think all of
them are like, we're going to have people like Kyla who who like
are willing to have a conversation and agree with us on so much?
>> I don't really agree with you on >> What? Nothing.
>> And he worked really hard. However,
I think this and again, the play is they're going to restructure
the narrative machine. The conversation is meant to look more
like it did 20 years ago and less like it did in the 2010s. They
don't want culture war insanity.
>> Who is they, Tim? Who's they? You're you're doing a
bunch of talking, a bunch of yapping. >> They're trying
to bring it all back together. So, again, let me put it like
this. the rumors that I'm hearing, and this could be all just
nonsense, but from uh staffers and and and lobbyists and people
in DC, is the play that's happening right now, like why is Tucker
Carlson all of a sudden saying, "Oh, this is a bad I oppose this."
When only several years ago he was like, "Iran is a serious threat.
>> People can't change their mind. >> He can, but
he's friends." >> Wait, why does Iran being a serious threat
mean like boots on the ground in Iran? Also, okay, there's just
multiple reasons that you could have your mind changed on this.
And that's not even indicative saying Iran's a serious threat
is not indicative of war with Iran must happen. It's not the
same >> with Trump and this is the game plan. >> He's
better friends and fans >> indeed. And the game plan is
now Alex Stein starting to sound like the smartest person on
the podcast. Oh >> If you want to win this that you need
controlled opposition. There should be an acceptable Democrat
and Republican party. And with the Democratic party and woke
being largely unfavorable,
they are going to they're going to try and create a moderate
space that will attract the likes of Joe Rogan because, you know,
he loves Tulsi Gabbard. And then you're going to have Joe Rogan
in a couple years being like, you know, I thought the Democrats
were nuts. However, Tulsi Gabbard comes back in and now we have
real leadership of the Democrats. I think they can win. That
that's the game plan. You can take every podcaster that endorsed
Trump in 2024,
put them all together, get them to endorse Tulsi Gabbard, she
goes from like 1% to 2%. Okay? Tulsi Gabbard is less likely to
happen than Kla Harris. Okay? Tulsi Gabbard is not going to happen.
Stop trying to make Tulsi Gabbard happen. It's never going to
happen. And this prevents culture war, civil war expansion and
allows for the military-industrial complex and the pro-Israel
element to maintain their wars and the liberal economic order.
Who who do you think is all beh cuz that like this is a lot of
really really really big pieces moving and there's also an assumption
that the Democrat base would ever consider like I I understand
you're saying the moderate the moderate rights right now shift
back to being the moderate left and vote for Tulsi but you won't
win anything without the Democrat base and the Democrat base
is never going to go for Tulsi. Anyone who has touched Trump
the Democrat base hates Trump so vehemently, anyone that's touched
him, anyone that's in their minds been sick of the question,
the question the question is going to arise for your corporate
Democrats. Who who will they get more votes from? The moderates
or the progressives? And >> no, no, Tim. No, Tim. It's
not just progressives that hate Trump, Tim. It's not just the
progressives.
And dude,
honest to God, I think Tim doesn't understand. I think the progressives
might actually hate Trump slightly less than the liberals.
I'm not I'm not seeing a lot of progressives advocating for like
killing Donald Trump, to be honest with you. I am seeing some
liberals advocate for it. Okay, so like the it's possible the
liberals might hate this guy even more. I'm just saying. Okay,
like it's crazy. Don't don't advocate for that personally, by
the way. I would never do that. But
dude, the libs hate Trump so much. It's not the progressives.
It's the liberal. It's the like neoliberals
despised Donald Trump. The play is >> to basically ice
out the progressives
already moving towards >> that's why Apac supported all
of these Democrats and won in Illinois to get rid of the progressives.
>> So So again, I'm going to stress this. I can tell you
this definitively because >> to get rid of the Isn't that
guy a
I'm pretty sure that guy who won is just not an anti-Zionist
progressive. I'm pretty sure he's still relatively speaking like
very very progressive.
The dude who won in Illinois, he's anti-APAC. Yeah. Okay. Like
it's it's literally Yeah. I know the AP pack back he he's backed
by J Street is a different um American lobby, but
I I know what you're saying. in general. I'm just talking about
policy. I'm not even talking about foreign policy. I'm talking
about like domestic policy. He's like a progressive unironically.
>> These people have said it to my face.
>> The mandate for the corporate press right now is to
buy up podcasts and take this all of these independent podcasts
that exist are going to be are going to be pulled into HBO, Paramount,
Netflix, whatever it might be. It's already happening. Sean Henny
launched a podcast. Netflix has a podcast section. They had a
meeting in Florida where all these people got together and discussed
how they get in the space. It is the corporate mandate. NBC Universal
is having these very same conversations right now. Don't take
my word for it. Larry Ellison just bought CBS and they are working
on purchasing CNN right now. >> Well, that was my question.
Are you This is where this is coming from. >> This is incoherent.
Netflix has a podcast section. Corporate media is buying things
because Netflix has a podcast section. What is the What are they
buying for podcasts? Uh Last Podcast on the left obviously.
Okay. Is that wait what what politically
entity is like by random
random like I don't even know what last what is last podcast
on the left it's like just improv comedy isn't it like these
these podcasts aren't political maybe there are some I I don't
even know on Netflix I don't watch Netflix enough I just I know
I saw last podcast on the left last time I went on Netflix
CBS is bought by Larry Ellison why do you think that happened
um to take the existing news media and make it explicitly proionist.
Obviously,
why why are you saying something else is happening? What does
that have to do with buying podcasts?
What are we talking about, man? >> From Ellis, why is Ellis
interested in working would be interested in in Tulsi Gabbard?
And why would Tulsi be able to make a better bid for the moderate
uh like Democrat vote? >> Unfortunately, good question
from I mean unfortunately, but actually good point from Kyla.
Why the
would Tulsi Gabbard be a preferred candidate
of Larry
>> And like somebody like Gavin Newsome who's making a
pretty hard movement towards trying to connect. >> So don't
forget >> but don't forget about JD Vance, right? So these
elements are at play. But
>> you literally didn't answer a single question she has
asked. Is Tim's is Tim's problem, man. What is wrong with this
Trump support? >> I'm not entirely sure. Rubio. >> Uh
I think Rubio is the is the actual uh player for >> a soft
require throwing Trump under the bus a little bit. >> Trump's
gonna get impeached probably. So >> Trump's going to get
impeached and there's even speculation that Trump might might
actually step down early so that Vance gets in as president for
a little bit before Rubio takes the uh the opportunity for 228.
Again, I don't know for sure. What I can tell you is that >> also
conveniently allows Vance to pardon him because there I think
there's still some question on whether the president can literally
pardon themselves,
right? But if he steps down, that makes room for Vance to pardon
him before anything
>> Uh there has been there have been rumors around DC for
a while that Tulsi Gabbard was preparing to resign and she was
going to start doing PR moves where she views Trump respectively
so that she can maintain moderates. She's not going to play the
Trump derangement syndrome game. She's going to say that she
respects him. He's a good guy. The Democrats were wrong to go
after him, but the war is wrong. We shouldn't be involved. is
going to play the regime change thing. >> Yeah, but you
can flip once, you can't flip twice. That's a career.
>> Even if it wasn't even if it wasn't her, their strategy
actually makes sense to me because at least you get rid of the
progressive side of politics, which I >> dude, I'm not
even Dude, it would be fun to go and like actually
take some time and pause and think because Tim is saying so many
things at the same time. I'm not actually I'm probably not even
parsing most of it. It would be nice to go pause and like go
through this slowly and just be like what like draw out these
shifts that he's describing and what is actually happening in
his head and just look at the coalitions that form and how they
make absolutely no sense.
I'm positive this would be so much more if I wasn't just letting
like most of it breeze by >> think is the most radical
thing on the planet. And um and so if this is what they're thinking,
if this is what they're planning, it sounds like a nice little
strategy cuz even if Tulsi loses, if she is the person, that
still means it doesn't go to the progressive side like Gavin
Newsome. >> But who's they? Like who's who's they? like
who's the person at the top or the collection at the top >> making
these decisions.
>> So Larry Ellison is a big Trump supporter and Trump
fan
why would Ellison fall in line under
>> in an effort dude in an effort to get away from sounding
anti-Semitic. Tim Pool is like trying to describe a plan.
And who's they? Who's they? Don't say the Don't say the Larry
Ellison and uh Miriam Aden.
Don't say the Don't say the Don't say the He doesn't want to
say it. He didn't just want to say, you know, Zionist, the lobby,
nothing like that. And then he just names the two richest who
fund American politics. Crazy crazy stuff. >> Gabbard.
So if a Tulsi Gabbard candidate is in if if your choice
like if if if Larry's looking at who his choice is going to be
and it's got to be a Republican like Trump or some whackaloon
lefty, he's going to be like, "Can we get a Democrat in there
that's not a threat to us >> like Rubio or
um Newsome?" I have a feeling that it's I feel like he would
probably go for Rubio, right? >> There's going to be a
Republican and a Democrat. They want the Democrat to be someone
who's not a threat. They want moderately pro-war and pro-war.
>> They being
>> Trump's inner circle, the donor class, the people who
are buying up these media uh platforms and changing the narrative
on them. >> You're you're saying your point is they don't
want bat crazy,
dude, it's a skit. It's an actual skit. Sorry, I was getting
water. Oh my god. It's an actual skit.
Who Who is that?
the the rich people, the donors, the the elites. Dude, does it
not concern you that you are like twisting yourself into odds?
That won't be a threat to them. They want somebody who's not
going to be a threat to them. Who's they? Uh the two most powerful
Jews who donate to American politics. Wait, do you are you sure
you want to say those things? I don't know.
They're just the people who do it. Who's buying up the media
platforms? It's actually crazy. It's actually crazy how hard
he
I feel like he just doesn't want to say anything that like turns
this into like somebody could call him anti-semitic. So, he's
saying the names and everybody can see what he means when he
says the
>> So, so here's here's the issue. Uh they want pro-Israel.
>> They they want some kind of Israel ambivalent or pro-
Israel.
dude, so much arm twisting to get there. Okay.
Now, why wouldn't they just take
Newsome?
Okay.
Instead of Why do they need Tulsi? Why can't they just have Nsome?
Nuome's doing his role. He's He's fulfilling his role pretty
well. No, >> all of them. A lot of elites like it feels
like right now what we're seeing is like the battle of the billionaires.
You've got like kind of the Musk and the Teals like on one side
and then you got pro Israel. >> Yeah. And you've got like
Israel and you've got like the the Gates on the other side that
are very at contention with each other. Bill Gates is pro Israel
and and indeed maybe these people do not like each other. So
the play in DC with Trump, again I'm going to stress this. This
is this is the rumor the rumor that I'm hearing. I don't know
if that is true. Joe Kent maybe is just doing whatever Joe Kent
feels like. They want to take control of the of the middle of
the road Democrat position. They want war and they know that
the war with Iran is going to be bad for moderates. So, they
want to take control of a moderate Democrat space >> with
the goal of putting the >> Okay,
this would be less funny to me if I didn't know that like Destiny
talked about how he got an offer from an Israeli company and
if I didn't suspect that Kylo is also taking money from like
an Israeli affiliated thing. This wouldn't be this would be like
I could just mock it openly. Oh, you think you think pro-Israeli
forces are trying to take like trying trying to take control
of the moderate Democrat position?
Really? Really? I would love to make fun of him on this, but
then in my schizo brain, I'm also like, >> the goal is
your choices for president in 2028 will be kind of pro-war and
pro >> So bad and worse.
>> The way it's always been. Like again, the way I look
at it is going back, >> it is being viewed largely by these
these these donors and these elites that >> we must have
a narrative machine the way we did back in the '9s or the 2000s
where when we say we're going to war for the petro dollar, we
do not get media
>> Hence why they should be buying up all of these podcasts
>> and that's what they're already doing or drowning them
out with AI slop content or buying Tik Tok and banning certain
voices. So again, I I point this out in uh perhaps there are
grand cons >> Tim is quite literally and I I don't know
like maybe he just wants to keep his podcast. He is quite literally
saying the Jews control the media so that they can have forever
wars for
Like he is saying that in no uncertain
Now he he also includes in there that it's about the the petro
dollar in America too, but it's like literally the are buying
the media to make sure we keep going to war for Israel. That's
that's unironically what he is arguing. That is his position
currently.
I would never say that because I'm not an anti-semite who thinks
you control everything. But Tim, on the other hand, Tim's just
out here saying it. This is crazy. This is I didn't realize this
was the America First podcast with Timothy J. Fuentes. Okay.
What the is happening? Conspiracies I don't know about. Or maybe
there's not really and there's just a handful of powerful elite
billionaires that are making moves to make this happen. >> There's
definitely some conspiracy. Well, you know, conspiracy implying
criminal wrongdoing. What I'll say is this. We know for a fact
Ellison purchased CBS. They're making a bid for Warner Brothers,
which would give them CNN as well. And we know that they're part
of the group that is acquiring Tik Tok explicitly because of
Israel. >> Tik Tok had a massive amount of anti-Israel
content. >> 84% pro Palestine. >> Pro Palestine.
And this is this is not this is not a conspiracy. This is not
meant to be a shock content or conjecture. We know for a fact
that Republicans wanted to ban Tik Tok because the content was
was more progressive. Democrats said no. Then when Axios put
out this report showing that the majority of the content after
October 7th flipped to pro Palestine, all of a sudden all the
Democrats were on board and they said yes, we should ban. This
is some crazy dude. He is quite literally
I don't necessarily think he's like wrong on a lot of these things,
but I do know that he's totally avoided topics like this for
a long time. He's the guy who had Kanye on and started calling
Kanye like a dangerous evil anti-semite, too. Which I mean Kanye
was anti-semitic, but he's mentally ill. Like I this is such
a weird flip from Tim P to just go in this direction. This is
some crazy ban Tik Tok. Trump's strategy was not to stop the
ban of Tik Tok, although that's what it looked like and all these
young people were cheering for him. Trump's strategy was there's
a better way to do this. You ban it, people get mad. We sell
it to pro-Israel-American interests. We win.
Just off of Tik Tok alone, I think it is fair to see the play
for every Democrat, every Republican, and the investors is take
control of the media and pro-Israel and and the and the narrative
will be pro- Israel.
>> So, what's worse, a Chinese own Tik Tok or pro- Israel
owned? >> Is is wait is Ardite not going to point out that
Tim is like straight up calling out the for controlling the media?
What? I I don't know how she lets that go. How could she possibly
let that go given the other stuff she's saying?
>> Tik Tok. >> I you know uh I guess the the the
troubling thing is you at least have some recourse in the United
States. >> American Yeah. American owned company. I I just
Yeah. I'm trying to like see the through line of like what the
under the bus necessarily. You do know >> if he by the
way all of this like totally makes sense if he just cuts out
some plan about Joe Kent and Tulsi Gabbard as if that makes as
if anybody believes that if he hadn't opened that way I would
be way more immunable to the things he's saying that like there
is a explicit play to control media it's being done like you
could even do it in the US framing of like to maintain the dominance
of the petro dollar blah blah blah blah blah by pro-Israel forces
who are gonna allow the US to support Israel. Like all of this
stuff would be fine if he just didn't include this totally insane
part about Tulsi Gabbard and Joe Kent. I don't know why he start
there.
He's been kind of he's been saying funny things. He's been saying
interesting things since like that happened. But this is all
trying to justify why he thinks Tulsi Gabbard and Joe Kent will
be the ticket for Democrats.
Why wouldn't it just be Gavin Newsome? Why what do they get from
from those two versus Gavin Newsome? >> They purchased
TikTok because of this, >> Yeah. No, no. I I agree that
the Ellis brothers have been buying up all sorts of their >> CBS.
They're going to get >> the Ellis brothers. The Ellis brothers.
What does she I know Larry Ellison's plastic surgery. He's like
incredibly bogged, but they don't really look like brothers,
do they?
Larry Larry's like 80. David's like David's I don't know, got
to be 50 or
>> It's CNN with the Warner Brothers merger as well. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I'm familiar with all of that. I'm just trying to go if
he's so proTrump, why wouldn't he just pivot? If he's got this
good thing with the right, it feels like there's a lot of still
like motivated energy behind it. I understand Iran's not popular,
>> dude. I'm going to say, okay, I don't
I'm not going to say I'm not going to say plastic surgery is
working better cuz he looks fairly alien. Okay, but like you'd
never identify in a million years that this dude is 81 years
old, right? And this is a fairly recent picture. He looks like
this now.
You would never identifi. He looks alien,
but 80. An 81y old alien. No. No. Like a 65year-old alien, right?
Like a like a 60-year-old alien. Not Not an 80year-old alien.
He's 81.
That's crazy.
He looks 9,000 years old, maybe. >> But just why don't
you just have Marco Rubio come out and be like, man, >> they're
going to have Marco Rubio. >> But why wouldn't they get
him behind him? That's what I'm trying to understand. They are
behind him. >> They're behind both.
>> You know what controlled opposition is?
>> I'm saying why would anyone think that Tulsi Gabbard
is going to successfully run in a Democrat base? >> She's
not expected to win. >> Yeah, exactly. It doesn't matter.
She's >> When your choice is pro-war or pro or >> Or
I should say like Tulsi is going to be the moderate. >> No.
Why would she win in a primary in a primary, Tim? Not in like
why should we would she win the election? Nobody believes that.
Why would she win in a primary?
And but it's it's also this.
>> Yes. So true. How do you feel about that? How do you
feel about that? How do all of you guys feel like say all of
this theory? >> I don't know. I guess it just is right.
Like all of all of my life until Trump won, this is what it was.
You could not go on TV if you opposed the war in Iraq. They wouldn't
let you on. All of these anti-interventionist uh uh uh personalities,
they were just on little micro blogs on the internet. It didn't
matter. Well, whether it was intentionally or otherwise, these
channels got really big. Alex Jones got the got nuked. He was
doing over a hundred million uniques per month and he was making
an insane amount of money. So they ban him outright. Nick Fuentes
starts getting really popular. They ban him outright. All of
a sudden then you have several Nick was banned when he was tiny.
He's just he's like literally not saying anything coherent at
all. Nick was not getting massive. Nick was tiny when he got
perma banned off of
He I if he had a thousand viewers, if he had more than a thousand
or 2,000 viewers, I would be shocked. Okay, he was not massive.
He became massive. He is massive now, but he was not a huge streamer
when he got banned. >> High-profile prominent conservatives
who were friends with Trump flip and now all adopt similar positions
around the exact same time. Now, I will say it's entirely possible
that there is a a global or cultural zeitgeist where this is
the content that makes money. This is what people are going to
chase. So, you can call Tucker, Megan, and Candace and, you know,
whoever else grifters who are just trying to make money. And
maybe that's really just what it is. But I do think it's interesting
that they all shift their positions at the exact same time despite
being friends with the Trump family and the administration. Yeah,
but it feels like the way you're talking about I feel like >> this
guy this guy
has been watching
Fuentes a lot. He's trying to take I can see where he's going
now.
He's trying to do the daily wire play. I'm going to I'm going
to take Nick's talking points and then I'm going to water them
down and try to not make them anti-Semitic, which terrible job.
Basically just calling the controlling media. But that's what
he's trying to do. He's trying to walk the uh the Fentes line
here, right? Fuentes talks about this a lot that he's trustworthy.
Candidates, Tucker, these people aren't because they all supported
before and now they've all flipped on a dime. They're CIA agents.
They're feds. Blah blah blah blah. Don't watch anybody else but
me. That's what Tim's trying to do. He's trying to do some of
that same.
Unfortunately, he is about a thousand times less compelling.
So, he's not doing well >> negatively, I guess, about this.
Like I'm curious from a conservative side like when you guys
hear like that the conservatives are maybe let's just say all
this this is true. How do you guys as conservatives feel about
that happening within your movement? >> Well, it sounds
like we're living on borrowed time then. >> In what way?
Like what do you mean this is it? >> Well, MAGA is on >> this
is it
borrowed like the for >> our voices this show this independence
that we have to have alternative voices. We're living on borrowed
time then. I think we were we were always living on borrowed
time. I think the idea >> uh Aerodite should not go on
shows like this. Arodite
Aerodite's not capable of doing something that's like totally
required when you go on shows like this. If people are going
to say totally insane things, your reaction should be modulated
by the level of insanity you're you're hearing, right?
And she doesn't have that. She tra literally Tim P could start
talking about how he keeps women in his basement and cuts like
little pieces of their skin off and eats them before going about
his day, right? And would be like, "Yeah, how do you think they
feel about that?
What do you think's going on there?" Like, she just has this
calm
demeanor when she's being told the most insane things.
Not that everything Tim said, like all the Tulsi Gabbert stuff
is insane, but it's like at some point you got to go, "Well,
that's crazy. Come on, man. That's That's crazy. So, well, I
She might want to So, I think she would argue I'm going to like,
oh, I'm going to, you know, not push back too hard so they don't
freak out. I'm just going to ask some questions. But she's not
forceful enough with it. She's not like She's barely interjecting.
She's barely interjecting right now. >> Yeah. That there
would ever truly be a permanent decentralized network.
Oh, I don't want to do it to him. I don't think I can do it to
him. We call this becketing. Is is she becketing right now? She's
hardcore becketing. She's doing her Becket. She's doing her best
Beckett impression.
I'm sorry. I love Becket. I love Becket. I love Becket. I'm sorry
Becket. I'm sorry. >> Commentary in podcasts was silly.
I mean, in in 2018, they were banning people left and right and
then lying about it. In 2020, you couldn't you you you couldn't
even say, "I don't know if we need masks." You'd get banned for
it. You couldn't even say, "I think the virus may have come from
the Wuhan Institute of Viology, which is a mile away from the
wet market." They'd ban you for that, too. So we we've we've
dealt with wave after wave of censorship and we've only had in
the past couple of years a semblance of of some kind of free
speech. >> But but just really quick, but do do you believe
if even if that happens the opposite must take place too sooner
or >> What do you mean >> a cause and effect? >> What
do you mean? >> Meaning before Trump you had the media
the way that it was. Y >> but because of that Trump come
comes along and the opposite happens. Will that happen again?
Well, it depends on the the the change in media, right? So, we
had uh there's there's a couple theories on it. Uh so, I'm actually
I'm actually friends with the individual who started Obama's
Facebook uh campaigning, which many contribute to his victory.
He's mobilizing young people on social media. And uh the perception
is or at least what this individual has told me when the campaign
was told to use social media. This is again this is like 2007
2008 like no one really knows what's going on with it but young
people are on it. The the older crowd the boomers and the genics
were like why does this matter? And it's kind of like the blockbuster
phenomenon. They take a look at uh actually let me phrase it
like this. You can't move until it's too late. Right? So, uh,
Blockbuster, for instance, is the biggest game in town in video
rentals. Netflix, uh, I believe Netflix was founded before Google
was. It was like 1997 or something. And they originally would
mail DVDs to you. It was it was kind of weird. >> Game
or something like that. >> Yeah. I don't know, but then
they had some streaming on their website, but some were only
available for, you know, for Netflix apparently was like buy
was like no. The issue is 80% of your rentals are at the big
store. And so Blackb saying look, we may be shrinking, but we're
not going to allocate resources at a lower margin to a new market.
No one does. So, the same thing is true for the internet. The
power that people leave the internet and say, "Listen, we're
getting 20 million viewers per night on CNN. why should we bother
with Facebook and then two years later it's 10 million and then
two years later it's 5 million and then all of a sudden Alex
Jones is is dictating policy effectively and so that is one theory
that we went through this period we we've gone through multiple
periods where you had as I mentioned the the Napster phase where
music was basically free then they wrapped it up in a subscription
and they got their money back then
okay he's describing something I wish he oh this is one of those
things where Tim's doing something I do I'll like describe concepts
I'm thinking about loosely without ever writing them down and
so I'm like I'm going to get get there eventually, but I don't
I should just write stuff down a lot more than I do. I always
say that and then I never do as well. But regardless of my shortcomings,
okay, Tim here, he's he's getting at something that's not totally.
It's it's that he's he's basically describing early mover advantage
and that early mover advantage on the internet has essentially
reached
zero. You you are everybody's already trying to get on in the
internet. Everybody's already trying to get on all of these networks.
So you don't have any advantage to being here anymore and you're
going to get crowded out by the best content and it turns out
he's is a like another effect here going on is the best content
it turns out is just pure AI slop that nobody actually cares
nobody actually really listens to or nothing good happens right
he is he's describing something interesting and that yeah all
these companies didn't do it before and now they'll just acquire
something instead of like actually investing in those markets
themselves. What else? So, and so basically these companies weren't
going to ever get involved and now they have to get involved
so they could reassert narratives is like basically what he's
saying. And so they're going to start acquiring and or banning
and or policing out all the things they don't want.
Okay. I mean, you don't really need this analogy to argue this.
I'm not sure if you need the the the historical example to argue
this, but I I don't mind the thing he's saying overall. >> Then
you had mega upload where movies were free. Then they wrapped
it up into subscription services or Amazon and now they got their
money back. Now you have the political commentary and social
media space where people are affecting the political worldview.
Okay. He's talking about like a a normalization cycle which I
I think is pretty pretty I'd say most people accept that this
is real, right? The normalization cycle even after the normal
the cable thing is another thing like this, right? that basically
the people describe cable this way as well that a bunch of people
cut the cord because they didn't want to pay for 80 different
cable networks and then eventually you end up at like 80 different
streaming networks, right? Like over time these same monopolies,
the same market forces will push things back to where they were.
So he's trying to say for internet commentary things are getting
pushed back to the way they were. That this is bad. The way people
are convinced right now is bad. And so they're trying to get
like the internet internet media to go back to the way it was.
I think that's what he's going for. >> And they're going
to wrap that back up, put in a subscription service, and get
their power back. >> But so I guess I'm still I feel like
I'm not going to answer this. If I heard this like my own side,
people that I supported to some degree are moving in such a way
to further crush free speech and control the narrative. My answer
>> that's not good. I like free speech. So I think you
guys that's like the your big one in the show. So how do you
feel about that? Like I feel like the answer isn't well guess
we roll over and like take it up the bum. It is what it is. Like
how do you guys feel about the fact that in many ways it sounds
like you're hearing that your own side that in many ways you
support my own side? >> Well, you've supported Tulsi Gab.
>> I would argue that the establishment powers and the
millionaires and the billionaires have never been anyone's side
other than the elites. >> You supported Trump, right? And
you've supported his selection of administration. I mean, it
actually be that it's all one big happy family tree on the argument
like the free speech crushing might be good for us. >> No,
no, no, no, no. It's that they're all they're all basically saying,
why are we fighting? Let's just be rich and control this. What
do we need to do? >> that seems bad, right? >> Yes,
it's bad. >> But how do you guys feel about that being
that your
>> That's bad, right? Yeah. How do you feel about that?
Bad.
When bad things happen is bad.
Wow. That's What is this show?
I feel like if people were doing this, if the were buying all
of my people and money or using all my tax dollars and and my
government to do monopolies on media, I feel like I would say
that's bad. Don't you guys feel like that's bad? Yeah.
How does it make you feel? Bad.
Thank you. By the way, I'm not doing the That's Tim. That's Tim.
That's Tim. I don't say that. I don't think that. Okay. I'm far
more subtle about it. That's what Tim's doing. >> Thank
you. But what do you guys want to do? But you but again why you
keep saying your side? >> Because I'm not on the right.
I don't support media companies are not on our side and never
have been. >> Sure. I understand. They're not on the right
either. Sure. But you've heard Warner Brothers is not >> Can
I respond? Cuz if I'm going to be 2v1, I have to be able to respond.
>> No, no, no. You have made an accusation over and over
again. The corporate media is on the right. Is not correct. >> I've
not I've never said that the corporate media is on the right.
uh you should make the accusation that Larry Ellison's on the
right and he is the person whose equity is is being put up to
buy CBS and Warner Brothers and get policy he wants instituted
at both of those companies.
We've already seen it happen at CBS. It's been very transparent
that it's happened at CBS. It is obviously right leaning. It
is obviously proTrump. It is obviously pro regime right now.
Okay.
Don't say well
don't let him get away with that. said it's your side doing corporate
media is purchasing podcast. >> No, no. What you said?
>> You said two names. You said Miriam Adlesen. You said
Larry Ellison. Are those two people partisan donors or not? >> That
is Marco Rubio will be the one that Ellis is in support. Tulsi
Gabbard will be the moderate slightly pro-wor but not totally
pro war. She's the controlled opposition that they're putting
forward. But all this is being organized in many ways it sounds
like by people who are supporting Republicans in behind Republicans
and believed in the Republican vision. So what you're saying
is a lot of people that in many ways were part of your coalition
whether you like like them or not are in many ways.
>> Now moving against your own selves to crush free speech
and my question is what do you do about that if that if your
theory is true? >> No idea. >> Yeah I don't think
there is an answer to that. I I don't I I would say I don't know.
support opposition, right? Support support people who want corporate
pack money out of things like >> but but the >> like
Taylor Loren
the actual like the the reality is supporting opposition is supporting
people that like want to jail people that supported Trump, right?
And people that that would would speak out against uh >> let's
let's do this. Let's jump to this. Let's let's jump to the story
from Fox
>> Pritsker pushes prosecutions of Trump officials as part
of Democrat >> Oh, LET'S GO. THIS IS MY FAVORITE FAT person
in the whole world, JB Pritsker. Let's go. >> Project 2029
agend. >> Thank you. Thank you, JB. Okay,
this jolly looking man. We're we're swearing off. Okay, you guys
ever watch Rome?
All mockery of the one god shall cease. Okay, all mockery of
fat people on this stream will cease if JB Pritzkar is legitimately
pushing this agenda. Okay, we will never do it again. I love
fat people. >> So, let's go. >> This is This seems
to be the world that we're looking at. Some kind of elite civil
war that's been going on for some time. The powers that be I
let Let me just start the segment by saying this. If you believe
that the the the Trump side of things has not been preparing
for the world after Trump, I've got a bridge to sell you. At
the same time, if you believe Democrats are not preparing for
a strategy to win, then I've got a bridge, another bridge. I
got two of them, actually. In fact, I got seven. You can all
you can have all of them for one great discount. It looks like
the Democrat strategy that exists today is lock them up and destroy
their lives civily. The Republican play seems to be we need to
create there's three spaces right now. The Democrats hate the
right. The the the Republicans hate the left. And the middle
of the road people are flickering left and right on various issues.
Sometimes they lean they lean left on a lot of issues. They've
been leaning right on a lot of issues. And so the play is how
can we make the left and the right, the moderates are the left
and the Republicans are the right. And then the Democrats and
the progressives just are not strong enough as a coalition to
actually win anything. The Democratic party will then have no
choice but to depend on moderates. the Trump administration will
then be safe or I should say Trump officials after 2029 will
not have to worry about whatever this thing is that Democrats
are planning to do.
>> I I just want to go back
>> like basically what Aerodite wants, right? This is he
we shouldn't lose sight of the fact that this is quite literally
what Aerodite wants. Democrats pivoting hard to moderates, cutting
the progressives out entirely. Like this is the thing Aerodite
wants for sure, 100%.
thing.
So would you agree with control opposition if it meant getting
rid of stuff like this?
>> Me I I am never I am never I am never for the erasure
of liberal uh like fundamentals. No, we don't. >> That's
not fundamentals. That's is >> Well, crushing free speech
isn't good either. So well this could be a weaponization of the
DOJ. This could be legitimate prosecution. The idea that this
will not turn into a witch hunt is completely
literally said if we can't get them criminally then we'll get
them
>> if it is the case that they've done something wrong
right >> no no that's not what civily >> well civily
can mean that you can't just like you can't just brutally >> apparently
you're it's not wrongdoing if you're found civily liable for
something that's not proof of wrongdoing
dude what what I will purport you did something wrong but you
didn't because you'd go to jail if you did something wrong
No, no, Tim. I could talk about Tim being Oh, no. I can't do
that. How do I do this without being racist? Being racist is
not e is not illegal, Tim. I could talk about how you are. I
could talk about your genetic makeup and what that says about
you as a human being. And that would be wrong. That would be
wrong to do to judge you for this, Tim. Okay? But it would not
be illegal. Okay? All bad things are illegal. No. No, they're
not. Not. And certainly not. All bad things are criminal. >> Civil
is a dispute between two individual parties and they're going
to bog you down in court and drain your your funds. >> Civily
is a threat of lawfare
>> Yeah. I don't know much about project 2029. So, it really
depends on what it actually comes to for be forming. But in general,
I'm not a big fan of large group pre-presidential
plans like Project 25 that get built up by a bunch of self-interested
think
I don't like any of these,
but I'm just posing a question. >> But you guys are saying
I guess we roll over for the question.
>> Does has Kyla brought up like the crypto scams, the
selling pardons, all of this. Hey Tim, if if Donald Trump is
selling pardons, if people come to him and say, "Hey, I need
you to pardon this person." And those people are taking money,
Donald Trump should go to prison, right, after his presidency.
The people who bought the pardons should go back to prison. Those
those pardons should be invalidated, right? That would be just
right, Tim. He won't answer. >> You guys said, "I don't
know what we do." And I said, "Well, >> doesn't mean roll
over." >> Well, what do you do? >> Well, you continue
to do shows like it's possible that you can identify something
as wrong without knowing what to do. Something how to change.
>> I agree. I agree. But I feel like >> they're rolling
over there. >> There's nothing that comes to mind. There's
nothing that we go what is the way how do we look for example
in the upcoming elections regardless of party the candidates
who we think that's somebody that we can get in behind. If only
there was like a unifying thing that all of the people Tim are
is describing believed in that you could just be anti that thing
and it would basically imply you're not supporting
this exact machine Tim's describing. If only there was like a
label. Is there like a label? How do we leave behind the >> Illuminati?
I was thinking something like
you guys know people do like the cat joy emoji and say like I'm
crying. I'm crying right now. It's not that serious. Well, this
is kind of serious. But what if we called these people like cryionists
or something? What if you were anti-rionist,
right? You could just be anti-rionist and then you if you were
anti-rionist and cran cryists are just the people who are a part
of this cabal. if you're an anti-Cryionist that maybe maybe
you could like actually
just use that label to to try to figure out who's a part of the
thing Tim's describing and who's trying to control this and then
you just go against th those people and that's like automatically
already you're on the right track,
>> Man, that would be crazy party ties to get good officials,
>> right? I'm going to I'm going to go back to what D'vory
just said and you know
There's a certain point where I learned this. I learned this
from the left, the Carl Pauper meme. Uh I learned this from them.
And you know what? I think they were right.
Sometimes >> tolerating intolerance is is in and of itself
intolerance. >> You cannot tolerate intolerance. And so
we should use every means at our disposal to make sure anyone
who threatens this is is removed or barred from power. >> Well,
what about your current president weaponizing the DOJ against
Jerome Powell? This is why this is not far, dude. I'm I'm going
so crazy, man.
I'm just gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna go so crazy. This is why JB
is talking about prosecutions and that send people to jail. And
that's like not far enough. Actually, you need to ratchet that
way further over. Okay. >> Oh, well. And having multiple
subpoenas blocked by federal cases. Are we >> I'm going
to I'm going to say I'm going to repeat literally what I just
said. And I saw this comic book about Carl Pauper where the left
argued, "Use whatever means necessary to stop your political
opponents." And for years, I and many others said, "Well, we
shouldn't resort to that." And then we got beaten to a pulpit.
And I said, "You know what? They were right about that." >> I
So >> if someone punching you in the face, sooner or later
you got to say, "Stop." >> Yeah. I started my career in
2022 and I started fighting other lefties who said the Republicans
are onlogically evil. To them, we can do no bad things. And I
said, "That's evil. That is evilness. are already giving up the
game. Right? So if if there are certain Democrats that want to
that want to break liberalism, that want to break more of the
Constitution to get retribution to the conservatives that they
are mad at, I am >> It's not about being mad.
It's not about being mad. It's not about being mad. It's just
>> I'm opposed to that fundamentally and I always have
been. Well, I want to make this D Santis that made anti-semitism
speech laws in Florida. So, conservatives will limit the first
>> I I agree. Right. This is why I think being a party
dieard in either direction is really dangerous. Right. But I
think we have to look at, okay, if we know that Trump is >> I
you know what I hate? I hate people using the apparatus of government
to make themselves billions of dollars richer at the expense
of every citizen they're supposed to be governing. And anybody
who does that should be prosecuted in every country ever. Okay?
And probably one of the most historic uses of office to enrich
oneself at the expense of everybody else is occurring
Okay?
And I think I think there should be no limits upon the punishment
that's doled out to the people who have done this. Okay? Absolutely
zero limit. >> Is already weaponizing the DOJ and you guys
agree that that's bad, right? and we go, that's not a good thing.
I don't know if the next thing is we go, well, if they're moving
towards a Marco Rubio who also wants to crush free speech and
they're already actively right now weaponizing the DOJ, I don't
know. The answer shouldn't be, well, I just don't >> Let
me let me let me ask you a purely
>> There are two people with guns pointed at each other.
>> You have a button that if you press it, their guns will
disintegrate. Do you press it? >> Yes. If if if this is
I just don't know if this is analogous to the situation. Do you
want to tell me how it's >> Yeah. The point is we have
two powerful political factions that are escalating the attacks
against each other and do you stop them?
>> or do you just say no, no, no, no. Let them all keep
doing this like the Democrats might win and then they're going
to weaponize everything. Trump's weaponizing everything. Just
let it keep happening or do we shut it down? >> I think
what we do, for example, is like recognize that a democracy needs
a strong left and a strong right. This is why when I'm in a lot
of liberal spaces, when for example like Ben Shapiro is standing
up saying there do have to be lines of who's in the tent, we
go that's good, right? I don't have to like any of Ben Shapiro's
policies. You guys, I don't know how you feel about Dentio. And
I'm not saying I you have to, but we have to look at people who
are saying we must play by the rules of the Constitution. If
you believe in democracy and if you think that this nation's
beautiful experiment of America is something worth fighting for
and you have to find the politicians and the speakers and the
pundits who do this like
I just want to add something like you you've said >> not
not an American citizen by the way >> a lot of philosophy
right >> uh today >> no no I just mean like >> that
doesn't undercut her point but I'm just saying it's like it is
a little true Pavlau encoded okay it's coded sorry just coded
not encoded >> you you talked You you make a lot of references
to philosophers and >> you know these questions. >> I
love philosophy. >> So you bring up the constitution
>> but but you must be aware that that is not an argument
to anything you're
>> let me just elaborate first amendment. >> Uh yeah
blasphemy was illegal when the first amendment was ratified.
Is this just the argument you can amend >> the left the
left's idea of what is protection under the constitution is fundamentally
different from the right and how each culture interprets the
constitution determines whether or not they believe it's being
adhered to. So when you say we must adhere to the constitution,
which one? >> I I would say this is where the rolls veils
of ignorance is so useful is you go imagine your
hold on hold where'd she hear about that one?
Wait, where where'd she where'd she hear about that one? I've
heard that I've heard that before.
Where'd she hear about that?
That's funny. You guys remember where that's from? That's very
funny. Kyla got that. I believe Kyla got that from trying to
chat and walk Hutch through a debate with Straight Raid.
Straight raid brought that point up for Hutch. Very cool.
>> This is where the Rolls Veils of ignorance is so useful
is you go imagine you're in a society and you can't know where
you're going to fall. >> What are the rules that you want
in
>> Well, I want do pro. I'm so glad that that Kyla can
sit here and straight up having never referenced it before just
take the lines of a communist of all people. A communist.
She's just going to She's going to totally steal an idea from
a communist. Is she absolutely
disgusting?
Imagine copying the homework of a Yeah, she's actually just copying
the homework of a communist on liberalism.
Hey, hey, you know what? The actual best way to talk about liberalism
and those values is well I don't but I heard this communist talk
about it once and she seemed pretty smart.
>> Agreed. Very cool. Define due process. >> Due
process means that you are not you assumed not guilty until proven
>> That is not what due process means. >> Okay. Due
process that's part of all of due process. Due process the process
of pushing against allegations against you. >> No, no,
no, no, no. Okay. Just I'm going to clarify for you. Due process
refers to the legal process an individual of their particular
circumstances are due under the law. >> Fair under the
law. >> That doesn't mean innocent until proven guilty
because due process can refer to civil cases all the same. >> It
can refer to executive branches. >> I want both of these
things then. I want due process and I want an assumption of >> The
pro once again uh when you say due
>> it means something different to the left than it means
to the right. >> Yes. But it also still means some level
of both saying we want fair treatment. I agree that pause for
a second. Well, hold on. Hold on. I agree that principally the
left and the right are going to fight about what the the way
that that policy plays out, but at least we can both agree that
that policy matters, whereas right now we're moving in a direction
where we're saying, well, maybe free speech doesn't matter. And
I would say we might have different interpretations of what speech
free speech must matter. The best example is the current due
the current process due to an illegal immigrant who has an order
for deportation is to be taken into custody and immediately deported.
The left argues the process that should be due is a judicial
hearing where he can argue his case. >> but that is not
the legal due process for an illegal immigrant. >> I don't
believe that this is true. >> It is absolutely correct.
The executive uh Congress has delineated all powers on immigration
through the INA to the executive branch and that's why the executive
branch has exe talk to Pisco about this. That's why the executive
branch has
I feel like I feel like Tim has talked to Pisco about it. I do
feel like Tim has literally talked to Pisco about it
this is one of those things where I can imagine how Pisco would
would dodge this in a conversation even right
about what's legally there. We're talking about what's morally
right. What what was the spirit of the law? >> Executive
branch courts. There are judges that are not. That's that's why
the left has been saying judicial warrant all the time because
the executive branch can issue an administrative warrant under
Congress. >> Sure. But the issue is you're saying look
it these are ways that we can interpret due process differently.
>> That's not an interpretation. That's the law right now.
>> Regardless what I'm saying to >> Pisco doesn't
agree with that. Pisco would argue I believe what the spirit
of the law should be. Like what what were they really going for?
Did they mean that the president can just say no no you don't
get a hearing? No, probably not. This is probably some kind of
oversight. I'm assuming argue like >> are you saying that
we don't have due process as a principle at least that we fight
for >> that what the left can considers d
>> No he's saying yeah wait what he's saying is not confusing
he's saying due process is a concept that is not concretely defined
therefore obviously you know the two sides see th that phrase
differently
for the right when they're trying to deport people when they're
trying to get their goals accomplished due process is the minimal
possible set of things they can give.
And so the argument is actually >> the process is inongruous.
>> And likewise, when you just signal at the constitution,
some people might say people will have different arguments about
what each constitutional um what each amendment under the constitution
means
with what the law actually says. >> What conclusion can
we possibly take from that claim? When a leftist says, "I want
due process," we must ask them, "what do you mean by that?" And
then you come to discover the left and the right have completely
different worldviews on what that word actually means. >> Your
answer is we can't we actually can't do democracy anymore. >> Is
that your answer? >> Okay, Kathy Newman. >> Well,
don't call me Kathy Newman. >> Don't call me Kathy Newman.
>> Wait, hold on. I'm trying to say stake a position. What
are you saying? >> Okay, Cath I don't know who Kathy Newman
is off the top of my head. That's not the lady who interviewed
Jordan Peterson and had that really bad interview on British
TV, was it?
Is that because I feel like I feel like not would know who that
is specifically because she's like a huge Jordan Peterson fan.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Okay. I was like that's where I think
I know it from but I wasn't sure. Okay. >> I'm talking
about democracy. I'm talking about the values that we hold which
is what the constitution
>> divor Yeah. Thank you. It is democracy what you are
describing where one side is interpreting the US constitution
differently than the than the other side >> and we fight
about it and we often have to engage in some level of compromise.
That's the point. The conservatives want to concern which is
their role except when both sides are getting too extreme to
the point where it's going to rip this country apart and they're
going to shoot each other. >> I agree. I agree. And so
the question that I still have to pose as people who want to
at least agree with these principles of free speech of due process
though the way that I think of free speech and the limits that
we have around it might be different than you. We still both
value free speech. And I say how do you we of course we do. Of
course you value free speech and of course I value >> free
speech. You don't think so? >> I absolutely do not.
>> Dude, I love that Kyla Kyla heard that and she was like
no you guys do value free speech. That's not what he meant when
he said, "No, that's not true. That's not what he meant." >> Different
than you. We still both value free speech. And I say, "How do
you we >> No, we don't." And she's like, "Of course you
do." He's like, "Yes, >> you don't. >> Of course
we do. Of course you value free speech." And of course speech.
You don't think so, J? >> I absolutely do not. I absolutely
do >> Maybe with the pandemic they want to shut us down,
but I think generally the
>> dude, I swear to God, there's something to this like
Bosch thing. Okay, the Vosch thing about um how people look.
Alex Stein got a Zmpy prescription. Suddenly, this guy's thinking
clearly. He's like giving charity to leftists suddenly. WHAT
THE WHAT HAPPENED TO ALEX STEIN?
Where's the memes at? Where's Why is this guy saying we should
jail all leftists? Where'd that guy go? He lost 20 pounds and
suddenly he's like a liberal. What the happened? >> We're
going to go to like root
moral philosophies.
the a a society, a social body with a shared moral moral worldview
can agree we all believe in free speech. Then they ratify it
in their constitution and arrest anyone who says Jesus is not
Lord. That's not free speech by today's standards. At the same
time the left >> why would you tequila sunset you need
to control yourself but that would have happened absolutely absolutely
gay
that Alex Stein he would not have been able to >> want
free speech has arrested people for hate speech far and wide
there is a guy who got arrested for rap lyrics on Facebook the
right has argued no we should be allowed to say these things
we should be allowed to post rap lyrics there is not a unified
moral view on what free speech is and there never has Additionally,
I will end that. The Second Amendment has never historically
meant that anyone anywhere can carry guns. It meant the federal
government couldn't impose a law over the states to stop an individual
from carrying a weapon. But routinely in the 1800s, men would
ride on horseback in a town and the sheriff would say, "Hand
over your guns." The view of what is the Constitution shifts
dramatically all the >> Of course, >> and the left
and the right are so divergent in this, it's extreme. >> Sure.
But that doesn't mean that these things can't be unified. I guess
my question to you is what's the conclusion from what you're
saying?
>> I mean, when you diverge this much, sometimes the way
to unify is to kill each other until one side wins. Unfortunately,
that seems to be when when the country goes like that divergent.
I I don't know what you do to like get around it.
Like what do you do when you start seeing these things completely
differently?
I'm not saying I'm not advocating violence. I'm saying that like
sometimes there are irreconcilable differences.
It feels like it's starting to get close to that. I feel like
that's to me it seems like mostly Republicans driving it. Mostly
Republicans being totally out of their minds. But I'm sure they
see it that way too. The right constitution I would define as
the traditional American constitutional republic and the left
constitution is a multicultural democracy. When so I don't care
what words are used by each other, but they are entirely advocating
for two different worlds. It has come to the point where they
are threatening force against each other and exercising that.
>> I believe we should. >> By the way, what what
did Trump want to do when he was elected? What did what were
they showing at the rallies?
Something her up? Was it her up? Was it
was it wake her up? Was it No, it was lock
her
up. Were we complaining about it back then? Were we No. No. P.
No. No,
>> we we whatever means
>> I don't know why I knew I knew that was going to be
a problem saying it like that and then I went for it anyway.
And of course
got some very up responses from this audience. >> Stop
this escalation needs >> I need I need to get back on YouTube.
The kick audience is not where it's at. Okay, I need to get back
on YouTube to occur. Unfortunately, neither side will back off.
That means if Donald Trump pulls a move with powerful investors
and billionaires to create a new Democrat Republican spectrum,
the progressives are not simply going to say, "Guess we lose."
They're going to get guns and they're going to go people. >> I
don't know what the offramp is for all of this. But I can tell
you when Pritskar is saying, "We will arrest and if we can't,
we'll destroy you civily." >> Okay. Did did you know that
right now this is there's a hilarious story from SFGate hundreds
of millionaires and this met like hundreds this is a large number
are t are are there there are services that exist to facilitate
the exodus from this country right now because of things like
that it is not a question of if you are a political player there
is a fear among high netw worth individuals I this is where my
brain okay we want to go off into we want to go off into this
land this is why
the US should not be using it. If you want to use your military
might to go after something, go after every single place sheltering
the wealth of the wealthiest people in the world. You want to
actually go do like an invasion that helps the American people,
go seize every single ledger in the Cayman Islands, go seize
every single ledger in Switzerland if they're not willing to
give them up. Explain to Europe, if you want energy from the
Middle East,
you are going to let us go to Switzerland. and Switzerland, you
are going to give up every single ledger you have and we're going
to go through and we're going to do an audit. That's what the
U that's what US military might should have been used for. Okay?
This entire idea that US military might should be used to go
after and do regime change in Iran. Preposterous.
>> The Democrats are going to bullshik your ass. Because
because this is like exactly what's happening is the idea of
these people paying their fair share is
existentially threatening to them and it should not be an option.
Okay? Just like it's not an option for people to hide like cryptocurrency
through tumbling services like something like tornado cash. Just
like it's basically illegal to hide your income if you're anybody
who's poor. Okay. Anybody who doesn't have that much money hiding
your income from the US government. Yeah. You're getting charged
tomorrow. Okay. We need that same level of fervor for all the
millionaires, billionaires in the world. Okay. Same level of
fer. >> Sure. neutral on the left. When project 2025 came
out, it was the exact same type of terror and fear because both
>> project 2025 had a lot of things that a lot of the left
viewed shrinking of rights political wealthy individuals are
fleeing, not Republicans, because they fear that the Democrats
are going to swing the hammer against anyone and they fear it
because sides are going to become further radicalized,
>> Yeah. Nobody's concerned about that with Trump.
We're not having like insane policy shifts at tech companies
because Trump will go after the companies themselves, right?
Nobody thinks that under Trump. Nobody's Nobody thinks Trump's
going to go after anybody.
>> They fear it. No, they fear it because the ballot measure
measure in California, because of what's going on in Washington
state, and because there's there's Roana and Bernie Sanders talking
about that same kind of uh policy
>> So, this is the thing that I'm trying to I'm getting
confused by. You keep on saying this situation at hand and that
both parties are going to ramp up and ramp up and ramp up and
we're basically engaging in like brinksmanship and I'm saying
to you what's the conclusion that we take from that because well
my conclusion is I don't want a civil war. >> Tim's favorite
Tim got to his favorite place in the whole world.
>> Civil war. Let's go. That's that's Tim's
What's the conclusion? Civil War on the ark of history bends
towards the man in the beanie. Okay. The long the arc of history
is long, but it bends towards Mr. Pool. Civil war. Civil war.
Civil war.
Civil
war.
God. >> Because I don't want a bunch of mostly young men
dying for this. I think that that's the worst outcome. I look
at this and I go, "This is the
I feel like Tim would only do this with like a woman, right?
>> This feels like the kind of thing you you just don't
say to a guy, "Then surrender." I Dude, he just gets very comfortable
talking to somebody. You know, it takes finding a woman to find
somebody less masculine than Tim. Okay. But once they're there,
Tim feels very manly. Feels like a big boy. issue are that's
not the answer because I look at this and I go
this is the issue are that's not the answer because both sides
well one of the things that can't be the answer is insisting
that it's just the left or insisting that it's just the right
answer >> is going to lay down their arms >> I'm
trying to
so the answer is fairly
>> not an American citizen can't vote in elections not
an American citizen can't vote in elections now she can have
an opinion I'm not saying that to dis dismiss her opinion, okay?
I'm just saying she's trying to she you can't vote. You don't
have the right. >> Fairly obvious, isn't it? >> It
It's actually not because >> you think that these Trump
officials are going to be like, "Guess I go to jail." >> Uh,
no, no, no. I don't think Trump officials are going to change,
but there might be noble, meaningful, good conservative Republicans.
>> That's terrifying that you believe that and you've been
supporting that side. >> Who said supporting what side?
>> You are obviously supporting Trump. You obviously support
conservatives. This is obviously has to do with what we're talking
about >> because you said that none of this matters. Any
rule of law, any values of what we've built our system, our constitution
on Yes, we are talking about these things. I'm talking about
>> I'm saying there are two distinct factions that are
ready to tear each other to shreds. So nothing's going to stop
it. >> And I'm saying if if that is the exact belief that
makes it inevitable. So and both sides are saying that right
now. And I'm trying to say I want to put inevitable. So >> why
did she say so? >> If if that is the exact belief that
makes it inevitable. So >> if if that is the exact belief
that makes it inevitable. So >> that makes it inevitably
slow. Inevitably so. Or makes it inevitable.
>> Sure. Either one. >> And both sides are saying
that right now. I'm trying to say I want to put my gun down.
That's why I talk to you guys. >> No, no. I I I get what
you're saying. And I just think the reality is it's it's going
to happen because that is the life cycle of a country.
>> Not a single Republican will ever tolerate trans kids.
>> It's not happening. >> They don't have to in their
state.
Let me let me give you an example that I've cited quite a bit.
Uh Oklahoma has banned uh abortion uh outright. >> Uh Colorado
has passed abortion to the point of birth for any reasons elective.
>> Mhm. The a potential scenario that I've given would
be a woman is 6 months pregnant and she lives not too far from
the border. Duh. Tim comes up these stupid hypotheticals that
are like freak situations and really don't handle the meat of
the criticism. Like the thing's proposing is correct, right?
The two states can have wildly different laws on
and that serves everybody in 99.9999%
of cases.
Why are we pretending that it doesn't serve everybody? That that's
fine. That's not fine. Sorry. Coming up with this is how people
would argue some of the trans stuff, right? They argue these
little edge cases and it's like, dude, why don't you just argue
the substance of the issue, the the thing that affects everybody,
not like one little edge person. I don't care about that edge
person. You have like a you have a biodal situation, a biodal
solution thatffect that basically prioritizes everybody. Everybody
gets what they want. And you're like, "Yeah, but there's like
there's like three guys in the middle who don't get what they
want." Uh, and and
>> Order of Colorado, she decides. So, in her mind, she
says, "This man is abusive and I have this child with him. It's
going to be a world of nightmarish pain and it could be harmful
for the child. I can't bring a child into this world." So, she
flees. The man's perspective is, "I am not abusive. I've never
touched her and she just kidnapped my child to kill him and she
doesn't need to. So what happens when she seeks to cross that
border to get an abortion? You have two states with polar opposite
>> It will not be tolerated. We already saw I think it
might have been Arkansas. They tried to have a woman hunted down
because she fled the state with a friend to get an abortion and
they said, it might not have been, I can't remember which state
it was. They said that it was a conspiracy to break the law and
therefore they needed to stop her. >> Wasn't uh wasn't
one of these states like straight up paying bounties?
Wasn't that a thing in like Texas or Arkansas or like Alabama
or something that like if you knew somebody who left the state
to have an abortion, you could inform the state? Weren't they
trying to do that? Is it Texas? >> At what point? I mean,
maybe the argument is that uh a kid gets taken by a stranger
and brought to Washington to get his exchange and the parents
go, "Well, that's that's life, I guess." I don't see that as
being a reality. I think the parents are going to be like, "Lock
and load, mother. We're going we're going to town." >> Sure.
I agree. The issue is that the idea that our country like it
sounds like what you're saying is the conclusion that you're
saying is our country isn't going to continue to exist as a democracy
as we've known it. And I'm saying >> it isn't a democracy.
>> Whatever version >> it's not a democracy. It's
a constitutional republic.
Okay. Kill
>> of America that we have now. >> No, I'm not. I'm
not. >> It's a constitutional republic. >> a semantic
debate over constitutional republicanism. I'm saying since Trump's
election, we have not functioned in any real democracy. And one
could argue that we haven't since the liberal economic order.
But my point is Donald Trump wins and he's Wait, he actually
wasn't doing the thing. Oh, well, he said he wasn't doing the
thing.
That was a weird followup. Does this guy like Trump or not? Since
Trump was elected, we've not been a democracy at all.
Wait,
wait. Okay, we're on this Are we on the same side or Wait, is
Tim Pull my new new best friend? and and they claimed for years
he was propped up by Russia even arguing the votes were flipped
by Russia and then launched an investigation and ultimately impeached
him. Then when Trump when Trump loses in 2020 the right says
Joe Biden the Democrat stole the election. There is no belief
on either side that there is a functioning democracy right now.
Uh, sure. But part of that comes down to we are under threat
from think when when you look at Russia gate for example, there
weren't connections that could be made to Trump. But there were,
I believe, 12 Russian individuals that were arrested that had
found to hack multiple sites and that were actually engaging.
>> And how many Ukrainians did we arrest >> Wait.
Oh, just ask what did they do? Hacked multiple sites. What did
they do? 12 people >> hacked multiple sites and that were
actually engaging. And how many Ukrainians did we arrest for
for
>> Wait, what what what did they do? What was the outcome
of what they did from everything I've seen the Russia gate stuff?
By the way, I I've made this argument to somebody and I cannot
remember. But wasn't like if you go look at the Epstein stuff,
wasn't he talking to like Bannon and then you know talking to
Moot over on 4chan to get like SL pole like [__]
like slpole like moderation in his favor or something. What was
he doing with 4chan again? I feel like there were more indications
of possible election interference from Epstein as a private citizen
than anything else. But like I don't know I don't know that you
call that it's not Russia. There's like a lot of election stuff
going on there. There's a lot of weird going on there. Anyway,
I I'm just saying that I think the the Russia stuff was actually
weaker the the allegations around Russia were actually weaker
than just overall election interference from different parties
>> manipulating election in favor of >> I I I'm not
sure. Do you know the answer? Zero. Hold on. Did they get
>> Yes. And instead they arrested Paul Maniffort instead
of the Ukrainians. >> Was he guilty? >> And then
Joe Paul Maniffort >> was he I don't know. I'm not familiar
with the case. Again, it's going to fall back to when the Dem
>> Paul Maniffort wasn't I I don't think Paul Maniffort
was arrested for anything to do with election interference. Paul
Maniffort was arrested with regards to FAR violations, right?
Not saying he didn't do election interference on behalf of somebody.
I'm just saying that I think what he got arrested for was not
to do with like undermining US elections. I guess I hold on.
I suppose FAR is a a FAR violation is in fact a undermining of
US elections, right? Technically, the Democrats took power
timer. Uh, what do we got left? Five minutes. I think we're like
six. >> Knowing that they've been >> I we'll we'll
find a nice like stopping point some way halfway through this
and I'll
we'll see. I I don't mind going longer, but if you guys don't
want to donate or if you can't donate, it's totally fine. Well,
I I won't stop immediately. I'll find like a a solid like place
to split. >> And propped up by the Ukrainians. They arrested
a Trump ally and then told us he was guilty. And if you're a
Trump supporter, you're going to say that's full of that's BS.
No one will believe >> Sure. But you already basically
said after J6 democracies basically over >> before J6 I
mean J6 was a was a was a product of people believing democracy
was over. >> Sure. And so the question is the conclusion
cannot be and maybe you just want to I guess toss the country
to the wolves and say it's over. I don't think that that's what
we should because a lot of good people die. >> I don't
think it's over. I just think this has to play itself out ultimately.
And again, going going back to what Tim said, if if a president
of the United States along with his CIA director and other IC's
are making up manufactured intelligence to try to prosecute someone
who's trying to get elected as president. Yeah, I don't think
we have a >> we don't have a democracy. I mean, they
>> what Trump's home. We don't have a democracy. They they
fabricated evidence and took pictures of it. We don't have a
democracy. They >> were they investigated and found guilty
for it and tried. Can we look that up? No. They went to Trump's
house, went through his presidential his daily logs, found a
series of things they determined to be classified, and then put
fake classification papers on top of it, took a picture of it.
>> Okay. And so, >> and then told the American people
Trump had classified documents. They were
>> Wait, I don't think Trump disagre
Why is Tim not taking Trump's like literal admission that it's
classified?
Trump literally told people. He told a reporter, "This is classified
information I'm showing you right now."
What was that? What was that story? He literally talked about
it. Apparently, they're saying that they took uh they they staged
a photo to make it look like when they investigated Trump, like
they found classified information on top of stuff. But Trump
didn't argue he didn't do it. Trump argued, "I did it because
I'm allowed to do it because I could declassify anything at any
point in time
The argument wasn't, "I didn't take that stuff. I didn't have
classified information." It was by removing that classified information,
it is automatically declassified. That is an admission that he
he had classified information. What is the daily
>> These people are evil. >> Ask her about this.
>> Just the left. I'm sorry. Did >> I say just the
left? I said the people who raided Trump's home and fabricated
evidence to put him in prison are evil.
>> Sure. Yeah. If that occurred in the way that you describe
it, yes, I would be opposed to these things. I'm not granting
you that necessary at all. >> When When did we ever have
Ukraine gate? Why don't we spend $30 million on a Muller probe
to investigate the Ukrainians who interfered in the election?
Donald Trump wasn't the only presidential candidate 2017. It's
a good question. Donald Trump was >> It's a good question
cuz Trump Trump had no problem with uh with the Ukrainians in
2017.
>> Presidential candidate whose campaign was boosted by
officials from a former Soviet blocked country. Ukrainian government
officials tried to help Hillary Clinton to undermine Trump by
publicly questioning his fitness for office. They also disseminated
documents implicating a top Trump aid in corruption and suggested
they were investigating the matter only to back away after the
election. And they helped Clinton's allies research damaging
information on Trump and his advisers. A political investigation
found why didn't >> That's a good question. Why didn't
Trump do that? Who willing to weaponize the DOJ? Trump should
have locked Hillary up and he didn't do it because he's weak.
>> Well, he should have not locked Hillary up. This is
>> He likes Hillary. How did Tim go from getting so about
JB Pritsker to actually Trump should have locked Hillary up?
What? What happened? Where how do we traverse that entire tree
that what how
how do we do it? He just he was just about JB Pritsker and and
then Trump saying before the election he was going to lock her
up and then saying, "Well, he should have locked her up." Wait,
maybe that's his point. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Maybe that's
his point is no no actually it's all anyway and so he should
have just jailed his enemies cuz they're going to try to jail
him. >> There isn't. We should throw away due process.
The actual answer is we must demand due process. >> Who
said anything about throwing away due process? >> Well,
locking her up assumes that she wouldn't get fair process. >> Criminally
charge Hillary Clinton over the emails. Yeah, >> sure.
And then if she is found guilty in a court of law when the jury
of her >> So I'm advocating for due process >> Uh
so am I. >> Yes. That she should. So now
that's the same argument she was doing with regards to JB Pritsker.
Why is it that when JB Pritsker says this, you're saying, "Well,
there's no way this won't turn into a witch hunt."
The Hillary Clinton stuff is definitionally a witch hunt. She
is not found guilty anywhere. The court the the case was referred
to prosecutors. They didn't want to prosecute it. >> Folks,
what happened is that many people were charged. There were serious
issues with Russia that was found, but there was no tight connection
that could be tied to Trump, which is why he wasn't arrested.
Is that Where's our due process? Can we have due process? >> He
was impeached over that. >> Was Trump not impeached? Yeah,
Trump was kind of impeached over that. No, >> he was impeached
over the the call to Ukraine Hillary. >> Oh, right. No,
no, no. The the call to Ukraine, find me something on Biden,
right? Right. >> And Hillary Clinton was never held accountable
for classified information on personal service.
Did he stay president? I'm not Did he stay president until Joe
Biden got elected or did he Well, he got impeached. Did he get
was he removed at the he wasn't convicted? No. >> Oh, okay.
What? What? What? What? What does that have to do with saying
he got >> Well, that's saying we didn't say he was >> People
can investigate. People can make moves in office to do different
things through legitimate actors and sometimes they fail. And
that is either a >> sign I'm going to step right back and
just say this. >> There are two political in this country
that are tearing each other's throats out. Nothing's going to
stop them. One side is is hellbent on engaging in psychotic evil
lawfare and the other side is is is is crop dusting it. >> Listen,
I do have said anything this I just want to say. I think this
is just a waste of time because it's obvious that we have a uni
party. You can look at Donald Trump who campaigned that he's
not going to start any wars. He started a huge war. You can say
that he was going to get rid of all the illegal immigrants. Now
he has all these multinational corporations saying we can't get
rid of the illegal immigrants. So we have a uni party. So this
idea that it's right versus left is just meant to make us argue
on politics.
Really not true. I'm just telling you
they're giving up. Would you take the uni party over no >> a
radical left who wants to lock up their political opponents >> over
Yeah, absolutely. 100%. >> Would you take
>> Is your name Alex?
Why do they let this special ed adult on to talk? Why is this
guy talking? Is your name Alex? I wanted to hear Alex Stein's
opinion, not your opinion. >> I'm giving you I'm giving
you choices. Trump has not prosecuted anybody for, you know,
Anthony Fouchy. >> Hold on. They just issued a subpoena
to come the other day. 130 subpoenas that went out over the grand
conspiracy against Trump. >> He's also subpoenaing Jerome,
but nobody's got >> dismissed, but not Anthony Fouchy.
I mean, they've even come out and said that there's side effects
of the vaccine even though it is safe and effective YouTube.
So, my point is nobody has gone gone to jail for that. And then
on top of that, I know people within the Department of Justice
that actually tried to go after the people that put together
the January 6 committee and they don't even want to the DOJ is
not going to prosecute the DOJ.
Happy family tree. >> John Eastman's emails are horrifying.
If you read through John Eastman and J6, he is explicitly saying,
"Hey, Trump, by the way, I need to be on the pardon list." And
multiple aids have already testified that they told John Eastman
that what you're doing is illegal, but what's happened to him?
Nothing. I agree that there are problems and that we need to
correct the system. But the answer to this isn't just accept
more erasure of our liberal rights. I'm not saying that you're
saying that. The problem is that your conclusion is there's nothing
we can do about it. But I guess I would ask how many people are
live right now?
>> Okay. 27,000 people is a lot of people. That means your
voice really matters. >> Sure. So what can 20,000 people
theoretically do if they want to further strengthen actual liberal
>> audience is so big Tim your audience is so big.
>> I think they should understand. >> I CAN TELL
YOU GOT THAT TROPHY. >> Go to timcast
and join our discord.com.
Get some coffee. >> You coffee prices are going through
the roof because of the war. Tim, did you see that? Has it affected
Casper? >> Uh our prices are unaffected. >> Okay,
good. Well, >> you can get some big booty Latina love potion
at the same same low price it's always been cash. >> No,
I think I think uh Alex, I'll give you a little push back. >> The
reason why they're dropping the mass deportation thing is because
they're losing Hispanic voters. This is what the intern this
is this is what they're saying, bro. >> It's because of
the when this first started, he literally said, "We're not going
to uh we're not >> home workers and hospital workers."
>> Trump owns hotels >> and he's got allies and his
men who are like, "Hey, we don't want to do this." >> You
also have the political class saying we we the Hispanic vote
for Republicans has dropped dramatically because they don't like
the ICE raids and
>> where what do you mean the Hispanic vote? What vote
has happened? What are we talking about?
What? Sorry. Has there been a major election since the last time
Latinos moved significantly in favor of Trump? >> Yeah,
Jess. That's why they pulled out of Minnesota. I was right that
those ice
don't agree that that means it's a uni party. I do agree that
it means that Trump's got special interests. >> You know
it's a >> Did I say there have been no elections or did
I say no major elections?
I actually you are you are timed out for saying explicitly things.
Um we'll do two days. You pay
two subs to get out of this.
Two days. Three days actually. Three days for saying explicitly
things and annoying me. Here we go. Three days. They can't even
pass the save act, Tim. They can't. No, I'm not even kidding.
They can't even pass the most. The most simplistic thing IS JUST
YOU HAVE TO SHOW in American history. >> AND THEY CAN'T
EVEN PASS THAT because there's Republicans who are SAYING, "OH,
I DON'T KNOW."
Will for it because like they're tying it to voter fraud, which
just like every everyone
there's no will for it because I agree with like the Republicans
and the Democrats largely are like, "We like the we like the
status quo." >> Yeah.
Walk the boat just like the DOJ is not going to say the DOJ.
This goes back to my point. This is to the progressives point.
This is why progressives would say we need to do things that
rally against like the progressive argument, right? Is to say
this isn't left versus right. The progressives reject the Democrat
party. They say we need a complete rev. >> It's not
I don't hear progressives talk about trans kids. I don't know.
This guy This guy's mind is locked in little kids. Okay. This
guy thinks about nothing more than the of 10year-olds in his
entire life. Tim, stop being a weirdo and thinking about little
kids, okay, for two seconds. Get your eye off of the balls and
onto the ball, okay? >> Bible where the power actually
shifts back to the >> I'm I'm going to lay it out for you.
It's very simple. >> They just also want to trans the kids.
>> So, a guy in a guy in a black hoodie with a black mask
on comes up and says, "The government is full of corrupt politicians."
And they go, "Here, here, brother." And then he starts waving
a red and black flag. And he says, "The military-industrial complex
has been waging war, killing civilians without cause for generations."
And I go, "Yeah, man. I hear you." And he goes, "Sure."
When Kyla says progressives, she means Hassan [__]
That's the only person she's talking about essentially. Hassan
[__] Maybe Kyle Kolinsky. Probably just Assam [__]
We got to change that. And I say, "Yeah, I agree. What can we
do?" He goes, "We got to put in a candidate who's going to put
a stop to this corruption, who's going to fix our voting systems,
and make sure that people's voice is heard." And I say, "Well,
I'm in. What do I do? Vote for the guy who wants to cut this
girl off. And I go, "Huh?" >> Well, I walk turn around
and walk off. >> It's just crazy to me that your number
in your pluralistic moral system of what matters most in voting,
you're like, "No, I couldn't imagine you could overnight say
I could we could wave a wand and you could vote away corruption."
But
>> I'm right next to you. >> We're trans. >> Tim,
literally stop thinking about little girls. Okay? Stop thinking
about the of 12 year olds. Stop talking thinking about the of
10year-olds.
Stop. Just stop. I know that's the only thing you could think
about. Stop. Nobody cares anymore. Wait, by the way, nobody cares
because your side won. Your side won. Unequivocal total victory.
Nobody cares anymore. Okay, you guys won on this. We don't want
to do it. >> Phil specifically.
How about how about people how about like just instead of take
take it away from the the trans topic. Like how about people
that are like we don't respect property, right? So we're going
to expropriate your property. >> Yeah, we shouldn't work
with communists. >> One second. I got to back it up cuz
I don't want to miss this part. So I'm going to back it up and
I have to finish chewing my food. >> I'm right next to
you. >> We're transing Phil specifically.
How about people? How about how about like just instead of take
take it away from the the trans topic like how about people that
are like we don't respect property rights and we're going to
expropriate your property. >> Yeah. We shouldn't work with
communists. I agree. In the same way that we shouldn't work with
like Nick Fuentes who is a theocrat. >> Yeah. Well, that
fair enough. But that's that's exactly what the progressives
want to do. That's what AOC wants to do. That's what Ro Khan
is talking about. >> Where is AOC talking about expropriating
property? Where why why is there a conflation of communist and
progressive? Those aren't the same thing at all.
Not even remotely.
There are no legitimate communists. Except maybe Bernie Sanders.
Maybe you could get Bernie Sanders on this that he thinks like
probably. But clearly, even though Bernie Sanders might believe
that in a philosophical sense, I've never seen Bernie Sanders
get up in Congress and say we need to take everybody's property
or whatever his v voice is. Okay? He doesn't do that. He believes
in incrementalism,
which is what almost everybody who's taken seriously in any respect
whatsoever believes in. The liberals never understand that even
if they throw leftists under the bus, right, the right still
sees them as commies. Perhaps if they themselves several more
times,
they'll see Porter Beller. But trust me, Republicans will see
I I just have to say Hassan is bad like a thousand more times
and then they'll see me as different than Hassan, right? Just
like a thousand more times, 10,000 more times. Gamla radical
left communist Democrat party
I can hear Trump's voice saying these things in my head it it
doesn't matter is hated by the communist because she moderated
and does a lot of bipartisan bills and is increasingly >> just
because she just because she the communists have a problem with
her doesn't mean that she wouldn't institute policies that the
communists want first of all second of all that would also destroy
the economy >> I don't believe that AOC would ever have
any political will behind her to actually do Sanders would do
that. >> No. Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders. Bernie, like
I said, Bernie Sanders and Roana are talking about a wealth tax
which will which they say it's only
they say no. But >> this is uh Bill is barely getting at
my whole point where
>> Aerodite can say, "Oh, no, no, no. Taking people's property
is wrong. Taking people's property is totally wrong." It's like,
"We should just do a
What do you think a tax is? A tax is literally you could tax
industries out of existence and take them over.
Like you can't just say, "Oh, well, all taxation is fine." If
you say that, then okay, we could you've given the government
full authority to expropriate people's property
to nationalize
Hey, you run a power plant. Well, actually, all your revenues
are now subject to a 95% tax.
Do you want to sell your p your plant to us at like 50% market
value? The government could easily do that. that is you are describing
a way the government could without apparently expropriating people's
wealth take it from them. Taxes are taking people's property.
It is the same thing. It is why you need to be careful like wielding
that power. Okay? If if you think that the only way you take
people's property is by like cutting their head off and seizing
all of their bank accounts, you're just wrong. That's not required.
Just cuz it is the most extreme thing you could do doesn't mean
it's the only way to do it. >> Stop. Listen. Stop. They
they say like, "Oh, it's only for the the mill." >> But
I'm I'm not saying that taxes are wrong, by the way. I'm saying
taxes are good, but if you don't understand that taxation is
a way of taking people's property, then you I don't know what
you're doing in politics. >> The billionaires and billionaires
cuz cuz Bernie's a millionaire. But that will cause capital flight
and then it will go get transferred on down to people that have
a house that's worth a million dollar. If >> you don't
pay your property taxes, what happens? They seize your property.
Exactly. So you could just argue that that's already communism
right there. that every year I have to pay taxes on my house
I already own. >> No, no, no, no. Alex Stein is making
the right point again. No. I swear to God.
You become more intelligent and attractive. Sorry. You become
If you become more attractive, if you lose a bunch of weight,
you become more intelligent and more left-leaning immediately
overnight. It's insane. It's I hate to say it. I hate to see
it. Bosch was right again. Bosch was right again. What are we
doing?
>> No. Property taxes are state taxes and you can move
if you don't like it. I'm talking about a federal tax. That's
why I mentioned Bernie Sanders and Roana. >> Sure. So this
is where like federalism >> state communism totally cool.
Federal
>> totally wrong in every way. >> America compared
to like Canada is really cool and that like different states
can have these. >> Well, that's why I specified federal.
>> Yes, I I understand. I'm I'm moving back more towards
like these broader conversations of like how we like try to unify
these two bodies, right? And the answer is if if you always will
have something you prioritize just preferentially over corruption,
I guess, yeah, then we're doomed. But I guess I would say if
we care about like one of the fundamental things that made this
country great that has shifted over time but is built on like
certain liberal polit not left liberal values like strong institutions,
balance of power, ensuring that like the votes have integrity
that we have some level of like regulation and and whatnot. If
you value some of these things, if you value free speech, right,
the miracle that is western liberal democracies, then you have
to prioritize
probably some other things over other things. But definitely
vote within your study against kids. >> But the problem
is there's a difference of opinion on what those definitions
are to those terms that you're using. One side doesn't see it
the same way. So, how do you >> Well, that I agree that
we don't see it the same way. But here's one of the benefits
of this latest kind of FCC pressuring of all these things is
all of a sudden all the progressives that I was yelling at three
years ago being like actually free speech matters even for people
we disagree with like conservatives now they're going free speech
free speech right now we're at
>> she wasn't sitting here yelling at people saying you
you can't do that didn't happen that didn't happen I don't she's
she's taking a position now and pretending she was previously
martyed for it which never happened. Nobody was fighting against
her that you need to like censor a bunch of Republicans. I don't
know what the [__] she's talking >> Perfect
type of position where a lot of the progressives, not just liberals,
but progressives are actually sensitive to certain there's there's
progressives that are 2A, right? Like that's happening right
now. We're in this poised position where the same way that like
fundamental rights getting removed and we're understanding why
these rights mattered in the first place. And what we shouldn't
do is go, "Well, the billionaires are winning, so I guess [__]
I guess we're like that can't be the answer." >> No, I
mean, but why not?
>> like what's wrong if like honest question like let's
say the the billionaires take back control
Tim's unironically,
okay,
total billionaire all oligarchy
and infinite wars for Israel to own the libs. to own the libs.
We must go to war with Israel for Israel infinitely.
And we need the billionaires to be able to run in a total oligarchy
in this country. They need to control all the media, everything.
All right. To own the libs. Thank you, Tim. That's a cool position
that you have. Totally not coded at all. And they seize media
and then everybody has a homogenized
Tim P will allow any anything to happen to his country so long
as he knows that
and everybody agrees almost like I swear to God I can't I can't
possibly think I don't understand at all what Tim is going for.
Oh, sure. But also you can rap their ass. Yes, the the oligarchs
can rap those kids so long as they don't cut their dick off.
literally anything. But
I What is the What is Tim's ideology at this point? What does
he believe in? But wait, what if they just mutilated a little
bit, Tim? Like circumcision, totally fine. Totally fine. A little
mutilation is a treat is fine. >> Done everything. It'll
be like the '90s >> Okay, Tim. Thank you. >> What's
wrong with that? >> What's wrong with the reduction of
>> I didn't say reduction of rights. Well, the homogeneized
society that we're talking about in this uniolar system is less
free speech, for example, because
>> Okay, let's let's just pause again and I'll ask the
question again. Uh the billionaires fund their politicians who
win. Uh they take the media back over. They they buy it all up.
They put in personalities. The the country homogenizes around
a a similar set of world views with minor differences where anyone
can speak their mind and say whatever they want whenever they
want. What's wrong with that? that that I have no issue with.
But it sounds like the system you're outlining isn't that. >> I
just outlined it. What do you mean? >> Well, the the when
we started the show, right, you were telling us about >> That's
exactly what I said. They want to they they they're going to
drown out all the chaos and the noise with AI slop. They're going
to put in their trusted personalities to create a homogeneous
uh uh uh moral worldview. >> And they're going to have
the same opinions no matter what. And what happens if the same?
What happens if you don't agree with someone? Tim Tim is doing
this is it's just so funny how Tim is doing this. Does this kick
to us allow watching Iranian propaganda videos? I don't know.
I I assume it does, but
I might have to disavow something. I don't know what it would
be. Okay. But
oh man, I just I just read that message and then >> they're
going to put in their trusted personalities to >> Oh, Tim
is literally say Tim is running like the actual
wignat talking points from like 2008
in 2026.
It's like totally wild. They feed you to make you stupid. Okay,
it's AI now.
So to it by the media, Larry Ellison, Miriam Adlesen, and they
could control your country via a uni party.
I'm I'm not joking. These are the things Tim Pool is saying.
And he's also like, but they won't cut the off of kids. So that's
all fine. So that they can have wars. So that they can have wars
for Israel. So that we'll support Israel in their wars and maintain
the dominance of the petro dollar. He's straight up. These are
the things he is saying. Now, he's not being overtly like anti-Semitic
and talking about and stuff in that way, but he is saying these
things directly
that like this is this is what's going to happen. It's fine and
I will allow it to happen so long as you don't touch that kid's
Oh, wait. With a with a scalpel with your hands. That's fine
for Tim. Tim's fine with that. With your hands, your mouth. That's
totally fine for Tim. Just don't touch that kid's with a scalpel.
There we go. Boom. There it is. >> Create a homogeneous
uh uh moral worldview. and they're going to have the same opinions
no matter what. And what happens if they're the same?
What happens if you don't agree with some of the opinions?
>> Like if if like you have a small percent of denters
who make blogs and do their own videos on YouTube. >> What
if you've got a podcaster who works for CBS who like maybe has
a different opinion, can they voice that? >> I'm like are
you asking if an individual has a right to go on someone else's
>> No, no, no. I'm asking >> they can go say whatever
they want. >> Are people allowed to have free speech? Are
they allowed to oppose things?
>> I don't got to invite you on my show if I don't like
you. >> Sure. That's >> when they all the news networks.
>> Yes. If your billionaires lead to a world where we just
respect liberal uh constitutional values and amendments and like
these liberal things that I've outlined, these like four things.
Sure, that's fine. I'm fine with that. But it sounds like you're
saying that they >> My point is when >> you could
totally respect the Constitution and have somebody have no voice
on the internet. You know how I know that? because it's already
happened to people like Nick Fuentes all like already that has
already been a thing that happened. Somebody was deplatformed
to the point that they basically couldn't get their voice out
at all and nobody has deemed it in like unconstitutional.
Nobody cared.
That's absolutely a thing that could happening that that has
happened and could happen again, right? Like it's I understand
that basically like a lot of people would agree with Nick Fentes
being deplatformed. I'm not saying he should have a platform
that he didn't violate to, but there is a totally constitutional
way to label people to violators or
like toss violators across multiple platforms and deplatform
them and they have no protections and that's like fine. There's
nothing there's no violation the government will get involved
in. Okay. So, I don't know like the idea that this could happen
again. Tim's describing something that has happened. It obviously
could happen again. And there are five streaming services. And
every person who's hired to have shows where they get a lot of
views are going to be either somewhat moderate on war or pro-war.
What's
like if you are an anti-war individual, they're not going to
invite you on the >> That's not a violation of free speech.
>> Sure. But the system that you outlined to all of us
in my understanding, if I I can go back, >> the political
elites buying up >> by a podcast. They restructure narratives
so that there's kind of the same two parties. They've got the
controlled opposition
basically everything.
They want to recreate Obama McCain >> and and you know
they can do this very easily when they once they put in a social
credit score. I'm not even kidding. You know that is how they
can basically make it
>> never mind. He's no
what? >> Well, I think they I mean if they put that in
they they just create more free social services and then we'd
all have to just behave and social already >> I know. I
agree. it. But >> the social credit score is just your
credit score. No, not just your credit >> Will be out in
the open. It'll be like your driver's license. You'll have to
check your social credit score to go >> You So that already
exists. >> Yeah, but I'm talking about like just out in
the open. Not >> need to do it in the open. They don't
need to do it in the open. >> So, uh, for instance,
there there are people who have gone on social media who get
shadowbanned and banned instantly. It's never changed. >> I
mean, like TikTok does it like crazy. >> That's it. They
they know who you are and they will shut down. I mean, look,
credit scores in the gutter. >> But things do change, right?
Like policy does change. Like the like yes, democracies have
a large preferentialism for slow change, but things do change.
Like the world looks different now than it did in the 80s at
a policy level. >> I take it back. I I think we should
have a forward- facing social credit score >> If we're
going to have it, it should be forward facing. >> Well,
check it out. Let me explain it like this. Like Nick Fuentes
is persona non grata, right? >> Uh and Richard Spencer
is largely too, even though he's not really been as active. And
Nick Fuentes was at a 90 out of 800.
He could do things to manif to to raise that social credit score
and then when he applies to for a PayPal they don't immediately
go ah Nick Fundes they go ah Nick Fes is your score your score
improved oh it's a 700 welcome
>> I'm kidding I really don't want that but think about
the alternative >> I think it's inevitable then >> you
guys are talking about the black mirror episode you do realize
that yeah >> so what is the bad side to it >> the
bad side is that black mirror episode where her day goes bad
and then her score just keeps dropping like crazy >> and
then it's over for her China China has it. It's nuts. >> The
most of the most of the homeless population in China are homeless
not because of any other reason than they have a bad social credit
score >> and they have a sign I mean they
>> dude I hate China and I don't believe
People who are perfectly like mentally well individuals
who have no other problems at all are apparently homeless because
of their social credit score. Uh-huh. Because every country just
loves throwing away productive workers for no reason, right?
>> There's a lot of Chinese.
>> It's frightening. >> No. Yeah, it absolutely is.
>> Well, look at New York City. Like, if you want to get
an apartment in New York City, the co-op board is can just basically
ban you for nothing. Like, if they just don't like anything about
you. And so, I think that that will be whatever happens in New
York, it's kind of can be extrapolated to the future of our society.
So, it's like we kind of already do like Tim says has a have
a hidden social credit score. But, I think it would probably
be better if we had a Ford facing one because then at least you
get some free government assistance or something, right? Cuz
that's why people will sign up for it because it'll they won't
have to pay as many taxes, they'll get a free car, free gas,
whatever incentive they need to make us agree to it. >> But
if you're if the if the Trump Rubio gabbard coalition that we
outlined at the beginning is moving for that direction, again,
my question goes, what do we do about that? Well, so honest question,
like if the Democratic party organically just >> this entire
thing has been Kyla saying, "What do we do about this?" and they
basically go like they're doomed and also they still think whatever
whatever authoritarian control they have to hand over to billionaires
in Israel is fine so long as the current Democrat progressives
don't win, right? Which like half of them consider Kyla exactly
that. Like they see no daylight between Kyle and Hassan, okay?
They'll allow anything to happen so long as that coalition doesn't
gain power, okay?
And not even win. They don't want them gaining a seat, like a
a tiny tiny tiny foothold, okay? They'll do anything.
And then at the very end, Kyla goes, "And then, okay, so like
what do we do about this?" And then they start again
moderated, right? Let's let's say that they were just like, you
know, Tulsi Gabbard is socially liberal on a bunch of things.
She's worked with Republicans, so she's got moderates on her
side. And if she genuinely won the primary, is that a bad thing?
>> Uh, not my my fundamental question always with any politician
is what's their policy? >> Right. If she's like, I'm pro-choice,
um, progressive tax, I want universal
That's So, you're telling me you vote for Tulsi Gabbard, suspected
Russian agent, totally duplicitous,
so long as she just adopted your policy platform?
What reason do you have to believe that she would hold to that
That's the dumbest thing I've ever heard. Well, as long as you
got good policy.
No. No.
You need some track record of actually being a trustworthy person.
Uh, but I like Trump. I could see why Kylo wouldn't want to make
that. >> I worked with him. He was he was good to me. We
don't need to be angry, but I just disagree with him on foreign
policy. So, I'm going to run. And then she wins the primary,
becomes the nominee. Is that is that a good or bad thing? Well,
it would depend on so she's flipped now Democrat Republican then
back to Democrat. I would need it's kind of like this like Kamla
thing of being like unc county valley of being like when you
remember when Kamla was like a progressive for her
can we just answer the question like if
which is using an example like a comparative example right so
the problem that probably would happen
>> well maybe can I trust that she's actually telling the
truth this time
>> that's not the hypothetical I'm I would like Well, if
the pol >> if she legitimately won a primary, is it a good
thing? >> It depends on what her policies are and if I
actually >> I No, it shouldn't depend. You don't trust
her. No, it would be a bad thing no matter what. Literally, there
is no involvement for Tulsi Gabbard that is good for any intelligent
person.
Tulsi Gabbard cannot be trusted. Tulsi Gabbard is so duplicitous.
She is so untrustworthy. She is so incapable of standing on principle
that the only thing she cared about, the entire reason she apparently
moved to help the Republican administration was because of how
Israel was handled because they thought she thought that she
could go and work for an administration that was anti-war. And
then that administration went to war and she shut her mouth.
She actually shut her mouth so much along the way. She knew they
were trying to force a war and she knew that there was no nuke
being made in Iran. And she never stood on business outside of
her congressional testimony when she was under threat of perjury.
That was the only time she said, "No, no, no. We have no intelligence
suggesting this." Right. And then as soon as Trump goes, "Hey,
aren't you like a"? She was like, "Yeah, I'm a massive." Actually,
yeah, I don't know why I said that. I don't know why I gave that
testimony under oath. Actually, my testimony is stupid. I'm just
a dumb. Why would you How could you ever vote for this person?
It's It's preposterous
the idea that this person could win a >> She can legitimately
believe that she'll enact those policies. >> Just say you
don't care for democracy. >> I do care about democracy.
>> Then why are you upset if someone legitimately wins
an election? >> Uh because if they're lying about their
policies to win an election and they don't enact anything, then
they're not a hypothetical. You're adding things I didn't say.
That's the point of democracy is that people give up their authority
to elected officials to enact their will. So doesn't do my will.
If you did not eat breakfast yesterday, how would you have felt?
>> Uh-huh. Now, why can't you answer the question about
Tulsi Gabbard if she is duly elected in the primary? Is it >> I
can I can do obnoxious dumb thought ending cliches as well. answer
the >> I'm engaging in good faith and I'm telling you why
there are issues of to it not being
>> um listen I don't I'm not a fan of Kyla that was it
is bad it would be bad yes
I don't think
it's yes the unfortunate
now hold on I should I should say I think Tim is actually doing
something smart here that was that was stupid but I think he
is doing something smart he's trying to point out that Kyla doesn't
believe that democ democracy and the will of the people is good
in and of itself because nobody does. If the will of the people
is being used to do something horrifying, then that is bad. You
can judge the thing that the people made judge the decision of
the masses. We do this all the time with Trump, right? You can
literally just say, "Well, no, Trump was elected and I think
that's horrible. I think that's horrifying. I think that's a
disaster for a country." It is not good in and of itself for
somebody to be elected democratically
or
pseudodemocratically
because he if if Ron
Kaperski won the Democratic primary is it a good thing? >> Um
potentially >> the people said we like his policies when
he won. >> What are his policies? >> That's not the
only question. >> Well, I'm going to feel >> no
the the honestly honest to God and this is this is the unfortunate
thing. I maybe I'm starting to see why she doesn't want to do
it. What kind of person is the is this person? What kind of person
are they? Are they a good
or are they a totally disingenuous scumbag? That's actually an
important question.
That's always an important question. Why can't people Why can't
people say that that's important?
He he >> and I don't know how I feel about it because I'm
going to be happy if a politician that I like his policies have
win and I'm going to be less happy if a politician that I don't
like wins >> I think you're being naive because >> this
is totally thought terminating. Yeah.
Tons of politicians run on policies that they can't get past.
They might even be aware they can't get passed. They might be
running on policies that they know pull well, but they know also
can't get implemented in any way. I'm sure lots of politicians
do that, right?
A lot of politicians in general are going to question
the function of democracy for a reason and you have no answer.
>> That's not a no answer.
>> Wait, so would you just be happy no matter who gets
elected? >> It is a good thing for a democracy when the
people choose their leaders. Yes, of course. Easy answer.
>> No, it's not. It's It's absolutely not. When people
are informed and choose their leaders, it's good for democracy.
I but I listen I'm I'm like totally convinced democracy has essentially
failed. So I I can I can admit this freely. People can't get
can't get informed. It's basically impossible nowadays. Okay.
When people are informed and choose their leaders, that's good
for a democracy at this point. Like hypothetically an alien race
comes down and they can mind control 80% of the population and
pick the candidates that are going to allow humanity to be enslaved.
Is that good? Because it was democratically decided? No, those
people weren't thinking for themselves. >> So when Biden
gets elected, you're happy about that. >> When the people
choose their leaders, okay, when the people say, >> "I
want my I'm not talking about I'm not going to get into specific
because you're going to you're going to create a culture war."
I'm asking you about a random random guy named Ron Kaperski because
I'm trying to remove
>> if Royn gets elected. Is that okay? >> Okay. What
if he has mostly liberal
>> Why did Why did she say I reject your name and I'm we're
going to use our my name? Like why what was the point of that?
Tim was literally saying I I've invented a name of a person
and she was like >> it doesn't matter that people voted
for
>> why is it hard for you to answer? >> Because it
feels like Okay, it feels like you're doing a weird thing. No,
I'm asking you a basic function of democracy as as a method to
lead up to the point I'm trying to make, but you refuse to >> What's
the point that you're trying to Well, I'm not refusing to answer.
I'm saying absolutely refusing to answer. >> I'm saying
would I be personally happy about it? It depends on what the
policy of the elected official is. Am I happy that democracy
is working generally? Yes. I'm happy that democracy was so >> It
is difficult because I'm not I'm trying to understand. Wait,
why are you laughing? What What are we talking about? Why? Why
are we talking about >> Tim Tim is actually so gay.
And yet I actually Dude, this is why Hold on. I hope
I hope Kyle understands that this is like a little bit of her
own medicine here, right? That Tim is clip farming you right
now. Yeah, Tim Tim is clip farming you right now. And I would
feel pretty bad for Kyla if she wasn't on this whole kick of
like, well, I got the good clips out of it even though I lost.
Like if she wasn't doing that kind of like explicitly not concerned
about winning on substance in places seemingly seemingly from
what I'd seen. Okay, she's talking about how important it is
to get the clips. I would feel bad. Okay, I think he's unbearable.
He is unbearable and he is not engaging at >> I asked connect
it back to the show. their elected leaders a good thing and you
refused to answer. You gave >> I was the X factor on this
show so I thought I'd come in and prove it.
>> [__] Ian Crossland. IAN CROSSLAND FROM THE
TOP ROPE WITH a top hat and a
>> Say something. >> How you guys feeling, man? >> Please
derail it. We've been talking about hypotheticals for almost
two >> Okay, this is what we got to do. We used to do a
lot of military philosophy
as well because we're the strongest on the planet. We have to
figure out how to use it. >> Ian, I have a question for
you. >> Is it a good thing if the people duly elect their
chosen representative?
>> What does duly mean?
>> It means legitimately. It means correctly and through
fair and normal >> It's it's um a transparent process that
can be used through a fair process where people say, "I like
this guy. I'm voting for him." Then he wins.
>> Ian's about to Ian's about to totally mog. Ian's about
to totally mo with no context.
It's a transparent process that could be utilized for evil is
what he >> But is it good if >> it's not good in
and of itself?
OH MY GOD. IAN got it instantly. Ian got it instantly with flawless
Ian victory. No, no re. Okay, GG. It's over. Ian won. He just
immediately came in. Yeah, it's like it's basically just a process.
It's not good or evil. Could be used for good. Could be used
for bad. Depends on how the people are informed. depends on what
they think.
If hey, what if what if the people in Germany, what if they didn't
take over the elections? What if Hitler was just duly elected?
Does that make the Holocaust okay? Probably not. Probably doesn't
make his election good, does it? If the people choose their
>> well, if you if they choose a bad leader, you could
say the process is transparent, but is used for evil or good.
It's like a neutral process. >> I'm talking about your
opinion.
Totally won. Oh my god, that's crazy. Ian came in and mogged
everybody in this room in two seconds while drunk and in a costume.
You love >> on the politics of the person. I'm saying,
do you think Democratic representatives are a good people choosing
their leaders a good thing? >> Beast worst. Yeah, >> he
wants a king. Okay, fine. King it is.
>> dude, just give the Yeah. What if the people of Germany
elected Hitler? Was the election of Hitler knowing that the Holocaust
is going to happen? Tim, was the election of Hitler good because
they elected him democratically?
Hitler. Do you love Hitler? Tim, didn't you get really bad because
Kanye loved Hitler and now you love Hitler? That's bias. Literally,
>> if the process is legitimate, yes, it is good that the
person who gets the most votes through whatever system that we
have, electoral college, wins, yes, that's good. Assuming that
the election is valid, but why why were we talking about this?
>> Because you brought up what if you had what if you had
somebody who's like a perfect this is like hypothetically, I
don't even need the hypothetical. The purpose of the electoral
system
is to best represent the people in the country to make life prosperous
and good for the most amount of people and to vi like basically
protect minority groups and individuals from from violations.
Right?
That should be your only concern the only thing you're concerned
about. The reason I never advocate for a different system outside
of democracy even though I think democracy has failed is I can't
think of a a different system that produces better outcomes.
There is no better system that produces like better outcomes
currently. And so I don't advocate for anything else. I just
say I think it's failed, but like it is what it is. You got to
ride with it, I guess. You know what I'm saying?
So, but if there was another system, if there was anything better,
I'd jump on that immediately.
And you should you should too. If you had something that you
knew could achieve like better outcomes for you, you should want
to jump on it. brought up the Tulsi Gabbard Gabbard Trump ticket
and the billionaires backing them. And so the question I'm asking
is if the voters did want Tulsi, is it bad that she wins? >> Not
necessarily. No. >> Right. That's that's my point. If you
look at it through the political the lens of political minations,
you're going to hate every politician ever. >> I'm I'm
not inherently opposed to Gabbard. What my my actual position
that I was outlining here that you were initially pushing back
on was I was saying, well, aren't we concerned that if Gabbard
is just a >> Sure, it won't be known in advance. I mean,
you could have a good idea.
What What if you invent um AGI
and basically this AGI is following the laws of robotics? It's
not hurting humans, but
it won't without the consent of most people take over and produce
like incredible outcomes for humanity.
does. So you you basically have a choice where you have a good
idea that this thing is going to like actually take the wheel
and produce way better outcomes for Yeah. machine God. Yeah,
exactly. Like you could come up with the hypothetical. You're
right that it's like not necessarily It's just trying to point
out that democracy in and of itself just happens to best represent
people, happens to best viol like happens to violate people least.
It's not good in and of itself. Well, maybe you could say that
makes it good in and of itself, but I I do believe the information
environment, you can't really say democracy is good without talking
about how informed the voters >> Controlled opposition
and it's not a legitimate person and she's just going to not
do the policies that she runs on. I would look at that and go
that isn't as legitimate as of democracy because then we essentially
have a charlatan, right? We have somebody who's saying I'll do
this, but she's actually just controlled by the other party and
won't necessarily do that thing. Okay. I don't want a puppet
democracy.
all the time. >> Well, to some extent we like there's actually
this like really interesting political theory that says all civilians
to some degree assume that politicians are lying, but we also
still want politicians to enact like 60% of their policy. Well,
we're upset, right? This is why people upset with Trump. He ran
on no wars >> and now he's not doing that, which is why
deportations >> and they should be upset because he's defying
what is otherwise legitimate authority that the people gave to
him.
The the crazy thing is he's not just like if you fail to enact
universal healthcare, okay, as Obama,
that's a failure, but it's not that insane a failure. Trump is
literally
usurping authority from Congress to go to war with another country
against the will of Congress, against the well, sorry, maybe
not against the will of Congress at this point, but against the
will of the people, and against his own promises. He is in like
a very top- down authoritarian fashion deciding that they're
going to do that. It's like Biden says he's actually he's going
to cancel student debt and then he gets in office and by executive
order he adds $10,000 to every person who has a student loan.
He adds $10,000 to their debt. It's like explicitly using executive
authority in a way that is directly oppositional to the thing
you ran on in a way that is only you making the decision.
It's it's like a crazy betrayal. It's not even like a little
betrayal as in you failed. Maybe you could have got it done if
you worked really hard and you just came up short. It's not that.
You have just failed entirely. >> That's why people are
upset. So if Tulsi got elected and ran on what she said she would
do, then that's fine. But if Tulsi gets elected and she doesn't
and she's a sellout to the other side, we get it. That's bad.
The the issue that I'm I'm largely getting to is like >> there
is no politician anywhere that legitimately runs. It doesn't
exist in this country. There has to be a special interest behind
them. And when they do get elected to Congress, they have to
cut a deal with like the NRCC or the DC.
There is no such thing in this country as a duly elected representative
in my >> Tucker Carlson could be >> I I do not believe
so. >> Do you think so? Do you think that if compromise
occurs in with any official is that not legitimate?
>> Compromise is okay.
>> My my point is that like >> are you anti- lobby
groups? Is that kind of what you're getting at? >> I am.
I'll leave you there. >> But but the problem with lobbying
is that people don't understand what it is. It's like >> like
I I've lobbied. >> I've I uh uh I have lobbyed inadvertently
West Virginia politicians over Maha issues. >> What about
it? >> Literally was just like I was on the phone with
a high-ranking uh member of the government in West Virginia >> and
the subject of Maha banning artificial dyes came up and I said,
"Oh man, I hope this happens." And they were like, "Really?"
And I said, "I'm I'm I think we got to get rid of all that stuff."
And I was like, I think it would be great because if you're in
if you're in PA, Ohio, Kentucky or Maryland or Virginia and you
know that you can drive like 3 miles to go to a supermarket in
West Virginia and you'll have no garbage in your food. I think
tons of moms are going to do it. I think suburban moms are going
to drive that extra three miles and that could be great for the
economy. I'd love for that to happen. Next thing I know, there
was a meeting between the governor and RFK Jr. >> Sure.
So >> I was like, "Oh, >> right. Lobbying is legitimate,
right? And it is actually it's important because for example
corporations can't vote and so it's a way for corporations to
still have some level of capacity
all the capacity super
multinational corporations. >> I gave you guys an example
of like guys guys I gave you an example of like lobbying that
I was doing but I'll give you an example of like actual lobbying
right like how it actually works.
A guy will go and meet with a member of Congress and they'll
sit down for a steak dinner and >> it's actually probably
not Apac so much as unless you count Apac as like a grooming
ground by which you can create super golems like Lindsey Graham.
That that would maybe be the only way you could get there is
essentially Apac allows you to create Lindsey Graham in the first
place. But realistically though, lobbying happened more or less
>> and they'll be discussing policy and it's not all that
crazy. And then the lobbyist will say something like, "If you
don't uh back this bill to fund Israel, I'll release videos of
you children." And then they go, "Oh, okay. I'll vote for that
bill." And then they shake hands. >> So that happens.
Is that legitimate though or
>> That's illegitimate, but it happens. Is that A REAL
QUESTION? >> NO. NO. I'm I'm making sure we're all on the
same terms. I'm saying, is that legitimate or illegitimate? That
is de facto illegitimate because it was Israel. If it was another
country,
obviously, yes. But if it was a lobby group that wasn't blackmailing,
but was just, you know, trying to be like, hey, well, you I agree.
I totally agree. But so when you said there's no legitimate authority,
I guess the question goes, is that because >> the issue
isn't lobbying, though? The issue isn't lobbying. So, uh, for
instance, one of the things I'm working on right now is, uh,
I'm going to I'm going to I am going to drop a political nuclear
bomb on this country, and I'm going to let you guys in on what's
going on. So, uh, the lodge the Lodge Card Club in Texas was
raided by the TABC. The, uh, search warrant was released. This
is the biggest poker club in the world. Now, maybe not really
because there could be underground clubs and things like that,
whatever. But in terms of a building just for playing poker and
various poker games and live streaming and culture, >> the
most square footage, >> the most square footage, the most
tables, it might not be the most square footage, but the most
tables, >> uh, they get rated for illegal gambling and
uh, money laundering because in Texas, uh, you cannot run a gambling
operation as a house. The way it works in Texas, however, is
card clubs emerged because they allow private games where you
pay a membership fee, and that's actually within the law. Well,
here's the thing. Here's the thing. I have beef with every single
state and you will too. If I were to ask each and every one of
you if you think uh gambling is good, I already know what everyone's
going to say. Absolutely not. It's bad. You think so? It's bad.
>> Yeah, I do. >> Okay. No problem. I agree. I completely
agree. And uh it's degeneracy and poker is gambling.
>> Dude, get to the point.
>> You say it's not, but I do. >> No, that's fine.
That's fine if you agree that. Okay. So, the law says you can't
gamble. And guess what? Every state says you can't gambling is
defined as wagering money on a game that involves any amount
of chance
where you can win prizes.
What did I just describe? >> Pokémon Go Pokemon card game.
Pokemon where today the regional champions took regional championships
took place in Houston where children wager $80
for a $71,000 prize pool with a $10,000 cash prize for first
place.
Okay, but
sure. I see where he's getting at that the line delineating poker
from
like any chancebased like drafting game, any card game essentially
where you shuffle the deck and now you have odds that basically
there's no difference between the Magic the Gathering World Championships
and the World Series of Poker. This is I understand I understand
what he's saying there. There is some element of chance going
on, right? You choose your deck. You can choose your deck, but
it's still chance, right? It's still absolutely chance-based.
Well, he's arguing that uh like basically you'd have like video
game tournaments, right? And in something like Counter-Strike,
it's not really chance-based. It's basically all deterministic.
Okay, so a Counter-Strike tournament is okay. But then if you
move into some something like Hearthstone, Hearthstone is not
significantly different. You build decks. Building the deck doesn't
matter. It's still probability.
It's still chance based. You are literally building a deck to
try to create to try to manufacture certain certain outcomes
probabilistically.
It is chance-based. So the entire point he's trying to make is
that with poker there is some skill element there. And because
they won't allow the skill element to outweigh the chance element
that rating this poker place but allowing all these card game
tournaments and to happen is wrong.
It's like I I understand that that the line delineating them
is not that strong >> on a card game of chance which is
illegal in the state of Texas, but they don't care. And this
me off now in West
I mean he he could say this. What if people were what if there
was a I do think that's different like a tournament where people
are playing against each other and they do an entry fee and then
there's like some amount of prize at the end. That's that feels
quite different to me in terms of a competition
than a infinitely running membersonly poker
like building that has tables that where the stakes could be
much higher where you could spend much more money.
>> I've been talking to the uh that their government for
some time and I said look the last thing we want is like casinos
popping up like crazy.
>> Wait, they got charged with moneyaundering too? Oh,
so it's like something else they were getting like arrested for.
something else they were getting in trouble for. But they probably
threw the gambling stuff in there on top of it to just be like
you. You're not getting out of this >> solution. Pokemon
poker, so it's just >> I already tried that. >> so
uh I actually >> Yeah, Pokémon. That's perfect.
Here's the idea. Here's the idea. You create a single deck where
there's four types >> and varying HPs. >> You could
definitely do that. Then you deal them out and it's a battle
where you look down at your Pokemon and if you have a strong
Pokemon team, you can go to battle with the other team and then
you have to use energy tokens to power like energy cards. >> You
could literally do that. I mean, that's it's a Pokemon. >> The
point is this. The point is this. I had a conversation with the
AG uh of West Virginia a while back before it was Morsey before
he got elected and I said, "We have an issue in the state where
you guys have like a thousand businesses where children are functionally
>> And uh you know, I got some laughter. I talked to the
lottery commission and they said, "Well, collectible card games
are exempt." So, we made a collectible card game called Debate
Me, which is functionally poker. And I said, "Okay, we're exempt
now, right?" But what me off is when the lodge got shut down,
I read that the Pokemon tournaments were coming here that operate
under the exact same structure. You pay 80. >> Yeah. X
is broken right now for sure. >> Bucks. You play a card
game tournament bracket style and the winner gets cash prizes.
That's children gambling. The law in Texas says you cannot you
cannot put money up front to use cards or any other dice or or
gambling device for a chance to win cash prizes with any amount
of chance involved. So why is David Busters uh legal? >> You
don't win. You don't win cash. >> But I mean, I guess you
could do this. >> You said prizes. You said prizes before.
It's not just cash prizes. Come on, man. We pretended you can't
run a lottery without cash prizes.
Like raffles are still regulated in a lot of ways, right? >> Poker
thing where you wear you win coupons and then
trade the coupon. >> And they still shut you down. So this
is the thing. The the Lodge Card Club did not take money from
the games. They hosted a membership club, a social club where
you pay hourly as a member of the club. Then you play the games
amongst the players and they got shut down for that. Meanwhile,
children are directly wagering and the company is directly profiting
off of these Pokémon games. >> So, here's what's going
to happen. We have prepared a lawsuit and I'll take it to the
Supreme Court. The states either have to ban Pokemon because
it is illegal statutoily under the law or
>> Wait, doesn't Tim Doesn't Tim Does Tim realize what
he's doing that you're advocating for? I thought Tim was a big
Magic guy. Doesn't Tim have a bunch of rare Magic the Gathering
cards? Does he realize that he is objectively trying to get Magic
the Gathering banned? All Magic the Gather Gathering tournaments
banned? Does he not understand that?
I'm pretty sure this guy got a bunch of like black lotuses and
Hold on.
Tim P. Tim Pool Magic the Gathering. Wait, what? Why did that
go? What? Oh, you Twitter.
It It loaded for a second, then it disappeared. What the Okay.
Okay, dude. Okay, dude. Sorry. This was Finding out Tim plays
collects magic is the most upsetting thing about this whole situation.
So, yeah, he does. Marjorie Taylor Green destroys Noob at Magic
the Gathering. Tim Cast Castle. WHAT? >> OH, because it's
it's Marjgery. I got it. They're doing skits three years ago.
>> People do get along and people work together and
>> anyway, he does love Magic the Gathering. Okay, listen.
I forgot. I forgot. Okay, I forgot.
I'm not used to, dude. If Twitter was down significantly, that's
like half of my content for my stream. It's just covering tweets.
Okay. Damn.
Anyway, >> it's blackjack.
>> Let's roll. Because you can't have it both ways. You
can't allow children to make wagers on Magic the Gathering Yu-Gi-Oh.
Now you got Teenage Mut Ninja Turtles Magic the Gathering. >> No,
he does get it. Oh god, he's going to get all of Magic tournaments
banned.
>> You got children putting up money to win
that is illegal under the law in every single state. So, we are
we have prepared a lawsuit. We have a lawsuit draft and uh we're
we're starting with uh West Virginia.
My argument is this.
I think West Virginia is uh and I'll tell you why we're talking
about this.
The casinos, you've got two big casino players in West Virginia
and one of them is Pen Entertainment, which is the second biggest
casino chain in the country. They operate, I think, about 42
locations. And it has been conveyed to me that the lobby there
is extremely powerful. Not because back to the lobbying question.
Not. Dude,
this was the biggest
counterpoints moment I've ever seen. We might have to like start
we might have to rename it. This thing where you like basically
engage in a conversation, tell a totally adjacent a totally um
orthogonal story that doesn't help anything
and pretend it totally solved the issue.
I might have to start calling that being a Tim Pool a Tim Pool
moment instead of a counterpoints moment. That's crazy. >> Not
because they will sit down with politicians and buy them dinner,
but because they threaten them. >> They say we will pull
funding from your packs and we will guarantee your opponent wins
if you oppose us. >> That is not legitimate. That's what's
happening and it's happening everywhere. >> Hey, I've been
screaming. I'm anti- carry committee. I'm anti-supacks and I
always have been, right? This is one of the reasons I like love
Roan is he's all James Terico is that they've run fairy >> dogs.
Wait wait wait.
Are you telling me
that you could advocate for something being better in the world
but not personally adhere to that principle yourself? So like
you could probably think the economy should be organized a little
bit differently without with the abolishment of private property
but not advocate for doing that through violent means right likewise
you could be like not so erodite and work directly for one of
these carry committees
while also advocating that they shouldn't exist
oh my god I think I h what I think I got it
that's it turns out that's a thing oh my god
Hey, this thing I benefit from is actually bad for the world,
so I think it shouldn't exist, but I'm still going to benefit
for it from it until it stops existing.
Okay, cool. I don't get the sarcasm. Um, nobody believes Aaron
when she says like, "Hey, I think communism would be good, but
we're not like there yet. So, I'm not advocating for like abolishing
all private property and moral." I'd never want to do it through
a revolution. Nobody believes her, but every single other person
is capable of doing this and understanding the nuance there.
It's just that I actually can't tell if it's a hate for Aaron
or a um a Hassan is bad moment. Probably a Hassan is bad moment.
>> Yes,
absolutely. >> That guy's a freak.
>> Do you you know you unironically like >> I love
Jameso, but I'm a liberal. >> How do you feel about that
he pulled off with Coar? >> Uh I don't know. Here's the
thing. My one of my biggest racist
tabula pasta. Thank you. It's also interesting that you refuse
to register a kick account and are using Twitch to chat right
now
like four hours, five hours after the Twitch stream has ended.
That's pretty cool. I I don't know anything about the Co Bear
stuff. I don't watch. >> So they they they they staged
a hoax against Jasmine Crockett to shut her out of the the election.
>> I would have to see evidence of that. >> So here's
what happened. uh Coar went on his show and said, "Trump's FC
I I was told in no uncertain terms by CBS that the FCC was threatening
us unless uh if we were going to air an interview with Telerico
because Trump doesn't want you to see this." The only problem
is the FCC equal time didn't apply to the Republicans or Trump.
It applied to Jine Crockett specifically. And so Telerico went
on Twitter and said, "This is the interview Trump doesn't want
you to see." When in fact, it had nothing to do with Trump. They
were trying to they were trying to make it appear as though the
only player was Terico and whoever the Republican candidate was
going to be.
They didn't want to give Jasmine Crockett equal time on TV. >> Well,
but this is the issue is late night TV shows almost never give
equal time because late nights have been basically exempt from
this. >> This is not the point. The point is >> this
is the point that happened with the this is exactly what the
FCC >> hoax for you because we're not talking about this.
It is a hoax to claim Trump stopped an interview when they both
were stopping Jasmine Crockett from getting equal time. >> They
they were not stopping Jasmine Crockett at all because the uh
the equal No, the equal like the the FCC policy that actually
was there's a really good um uh I think the Daily did a coverage
of all this story that goes into detail and it's it's >> so
agree they lied about what's going >> Yeah, I don't like
the lying obviously. >> It was a hoax. Trump did not stop
this. It did. It doesn't it's not
Yeah, Telerico was a lying scumbag. >> Okay. Sure, maybe
in this case I would have to look into it more, but in the case
it's okay. But the issue is my most important thing >> is
corruption
>> like Telerico's corruption where he teams up with Co
Bear to lie about Jasmine Crockett. >> Sure. He plays he
plays a little bit of dirty social media games possibly. But
but he's never taken a dollar of super PAC money. >> He
stole that election. >> He never did. He never did. And
he >> AP pack gets him some money. >> I I don't think
he'll take it. He's like taken a pretty big sw. I hope not. Right.
He could obviously disappoint me in the future. But what I'm
saying here to you guys is that when it comes to politics, I
have one really big priority right now, which is corrupt.
>> By the way, these guys >> in the government and
trying to get the
>> these guys are like jaded because they thought Trump
was honest and then Trump ended up taking a bunch of money and
changing his opinions and so everybody else is like Trump. Just
everyone is Trump to them. That's a level of blackmail that is
particularly >> man. A voice back in policy.
question. Do do you give any room to the fact that they're all
corrupt? >> Uh they're all corrupt to varying degrees and
I always want to try to vet for the least corrupt person who
will pass a policy that reduces corruption >> just based
on special interest based on money and politics. They're all
inherently corrupted at at a certain
to the tunes of millions of dollars through Lone Star Rising
Pack. Come on. And and I want to ask you about if you really
do like Tyler Rico, you know, he calls himself a pastor, but
he's also pro-choice. Don't you think that >> they're all
inherent of millions of
I'm not the tunes of millions of dollars through Lone Star Rising
Pack. Come on. And and
>> Oh, but I guess you can't stop packs from really doing
anything, right? Packs are supposed to be on issue lines. So
you can't literally you literally can't stop a pack from advertising
on your behalf, right? It doesn't mean you're accepting money
from them. you're not taking personal campaign contributions
or anything like that, but you can't really stop certain packs
from basically going after your enemies or whatever. That's just
going to happen. >> I want to ask you about if you really
do like Tyler Rico, you know, he calls himself a pastor, but
he's also pro-choice. Don't you think that that is >> Wait,
packs are not super PACs. Is he is that a super pack? >> A
super PAC. >> Uh James, >> Lone Star, Lone Star Rising
Pack spent millions on ads supporting him. >> Did he? But
Kyla, do you think he's a hypocrite for saying that he's a pastor,
but also saying it's okay to murder a baby in the womb? >> Uh,
no. Not >> you don't think that's hypocritical? >> Do
you think Jesus would be choice? >> Exodus 21:22. It seems
like Jesus made a very specific law that yes, if you kill a baby
in the womb, you can get like just a financial fine instead of
capital punishment. So, it seems like it's notically clear. >> It
is a it is a it is a in my opinion misleading to say someone
doesn't take pack money because packs don't spend money on candidates.
They buy ads for the candidate. And James Telerico has got from
allied from Lone Star Rising Lonear Rising Pack spent an estimated
$4 million in 2026 on ads supporting him. >> I mean that's
massive committ
fascinating the party who claims to love democracy. They sure
have a funny way of showing how they do that because what they
did with Jasmine
>> I I'm shocked. Uh, Aerodite appears to be able to have
like a
apparently she gets to have a laptop. I feel like nobody else
gets a laptop. How did she How did she run this? How'd she get
this done? This is
Lonear Rising Pack. Super PAC independent expenditure only. Statement
of organization.
Are they going to say what this is? This is a It's the pack.
What is the corporate structure? Can we see that somewhere? FC
identification
I was just wondering if it would say like how it was organized
if it but
that's it. It's just a just is a super PAC. I don't know. I don't
know what these designations mean. Super PAC independent expenditure
only unauthorized.
So again, independent expenditure only. That does mean I believe
they cannot coordinate with campaigns at all. So you're not really
accepting money from them at all. Right. You can't you can't
move
you can't move these P like you can't um move them. You can't
advocate you can't say run this ad. You can't say do this. You
You can have no coordination. It honestly makes you look pathetic
to have a laptop. Not on Tim P. No. Tim P always has his computer
right there and he's always arguing with his computer in front
in front of him. I think it's fine for you to have a laptop on
Tim Pool,
but he doesn't give he doesn't extend that to most people. So,
I don't know how Kylo >> Crockett is the opposite. >> Oh
my god, it's evil. And I don't even like her. That's evil. >> This
is this is just that like silly thing of like just point and
be like, "Oh, Democrats, they hate democracy." talking about
the president insisting the progressive election was stolen.
So he still denies the genuine transfer of legitimate power that
happened between him and >> and I have never agreed that
the election was stolen and I think Biden won large.
>> Okay, I'm uh this has run in circles quite a bit. We're
out of time for the night. 7:20 7 hours 20. All right, I need
to start earlier. I need to start earlier. I need to start earlier.
I need to tomorrow start far earlier. Okay, this is too late.
It's way too late. God, I'ming exhausted, man. Well, not I don't
know about exhausted. I'm I'm tired, though. Okay, I'm tired.
Okay. All right. Let me Let me go take a look. We are going to
morale. Moral's live. I'm going to shoot you over to morale.
Okay. Have a good night, guys. I'll talk to y'all later. The
forgotten Patreon. Dude, I I should plan out some Patreon content.
I think there there could be fun things for Patreon. I I really
do have like some ideas.
I think just more
I don't know. I'll figure some stuff out at some point.
At some point. Okay. Thank you guys very much for being here
tonight. I will be back
tomorrow. Have a good night everybody. Bye bye
bye bye bye bye.
Tell us more plans you're not going to follow through with. No.
I said I have some some ideas but I'm not getting into it cuz
I I might not. You know I might not. Anyway, go to Mau. Bye.
Bye. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night.